COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE I WILL BE MAKING
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
AGAIN EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES
THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED. TO
CONTINUE OUR CENTRAL WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THIS
PROCESS WE PRAY SHOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE I GO
THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO
ARE TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST
TIME. SOMEONE ASK FOR THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
THE DAY I IN ROUTE SPONSOR CODE
NINETEENTH AND THE EMERGENCY IN
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MIGHT NOT A SIN YEAH AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE NOT
ORDERS THIS WILL BE PUTTING
THIS A CENTRAL HEARING. MAY
NECESSARY. TO THE NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. WERE PUTTING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH PARK COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SENATOR BATES.
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF VIDEO
CONFERENCE OUR SYSTEM. I KNOW
THAT DOES SENATOR BATES IS
QUITE ARE FAMILIAR- WITH THE
NEW TECHNOLOGY AT THIS POINT.
SO IT IS A REMINDER THOUGH TO
MUTE YOUR PHONE OR COMPUTER
ANYTIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION. I USE THE RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM AND
EACH TIME YOUR KNOWLEDGE TO
SPEAK. A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE PLEASE SAID LIKED ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
AND R. I. T. PER I WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON WHEN YOU ARE DONE. I
HERE ARE AT THE LAST MEETING SO
JUST A FRIENDLY REMINDER TO OUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR BATES. AND TO
THE PUBLIC TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS. WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TEST BUT TODAY ALSO.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANTS TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND WILL
THIS BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND THIS IS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
OF A GOING TO BE TESTIFYING-
REMOTELY. THAT NUMBER IS ON THE
SCREEN RIGHT NOW IT'S EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE. IS. SEVEN FIVE
ZERO TWO ZERO ONE THREE. OKAY
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK
IN THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
YOU MUST NHI<c.cyan> THE DEVICE YOU</c>
ARE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT'S. YES. OKAY
FIVE LET ME CONTINUE I'M SURE
SOMEONE WILL TELL ME IF I NEED
TO STOP TALKING BUT ARE JUST TO
REPEAT OUR PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER
IF YOU WERE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
TO AVOID FEEDBACK YOU HAVE TO
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TO. AND THAT. FROM I'M GONNA
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THAT I ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE YOUR CONNECTION MUTED.
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE THE
STREET ON THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO OUR NEW ONLINE
TOOLS SO JUST BE PATIENT. ARE
WE WILL MAKE SURE WE GET YOUR
TAX MONEY. AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF OUR STENOGRAPHER. I WOULD
ASK ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES
AND WITNESSES A LIFE. TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. OKAY SO
BEFORE WE GET STARTED WITH THE
AGENDA WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND OF COURSE AS A
REMINDER TO MEMBERS YOU'LL NEED
TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE FOR
THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME WE
VOTE. THE MAN OF SECRETARY WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MINING HERE. MORNING HERE ROTH
YOUR- ROTH HERE WILK RESIDENT
WILL PRESENT ATKINS HERE ATKINS
HERE. THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
ARM OKAY. AND AS A REMINDER
SENATOR BASES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FROM HER DISTRICT
OFFICE YOU'LL BE PARTICIPATING
IN COMMENTS QUESTIONS AND
DEBATE BUT SHE WILL NOT BE
VOTING. SO AS WE BEGIN OUR
AGENDA I THINK IF MY COLLEAGUES
DON'T OBJECT I WOULD LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND ASK FOR A MOTION ON
ITEM THREE WHICH IS BILL
REFERRALS IF I CAN GET A MOTION
ON THAT. SO WHO. ARE THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR WILL IT MAKE
THAT MOTION MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI
MONNING AYE ROTH ALRIGHT ROTH
AYE WILK RIGHT WILK I ATKINS HI
ATKINS I. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY THAT IS FOUR ZERO I
pAND NEXT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
AND TAKE UP GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
THE CHIEF OF DIVISION OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT LILIA
GARCIA BROWER. AND LET'S SEE ON
THE LINE. THERE YOU ARE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AT WELCOME LET ME
GO AHEAD AND- ASK IF YOU'D LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ANYBODY THAT
MIGHT BE WITH YOU OR OR THAT
YOU WANT TO THANK FOR THEIR
PERSONAL SUPPORT GO RIGHT INTO
ANY OPENING COMMENTS YOU WANT
TO MAKE AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
GET STARTED. WELCOME THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
APPROACH TO THE WORK. AND
VISION FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE. TO
EXPLAIN MY APPROACH I BEGIN
WITH TECHNOLOGY MY RICH
IMMIGRANT HERITAGE WHICH IS
GROUNDED IN LOVE STRUGGLE AND
HARD WORK. I AM FORTUNATE TO
HAVE MY PARENTS VIçT AMINATA
I'M AWAY WITH ME TODAY. THEY
INSTILLED IN ME A PROFOUND
APPRECIATION AND VALUE FOR HARD
WORK THROUGH THEIR TIRELESS
EXAMPLE I ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
WIFE KELLY AND MY DAUGHTER MAYA
WEDDING COURAGE ME TO ASSUME
THIS ENDEAVOR OF PUBLIC
SERVICE. DALY THEY MAKE A
PRECIOUS SACRIFICE SO THAT I
MAY INVEST COUNTLESS HOURS TO
PERFORM THE JOB CALIFORNIA
DESERVES. I ALSO DRAW STRENGTH
FROM MY SISTERS BROTHERS AND
NEPHEWS WHOSE INSPIRING
EXAMPLES OF THE TERM SHIN AND
ADVOCACY GIVE ME HOPE TO PURSUE
A WORLD THAT IS NOT YET SEEN
THESE PERSONAL. BRIEFLY BUT
INTENTIONALLY BECAUSE AS A
DESCENDANT OF A BUT I SEVERAL
WORKER AND RIGHTEOUS FLAVORS I
AM A BENEFICIARY OF THE SOCIAL
CONTRACT THIS COUNTRY AND STATE
DECLARE. CALIFORNIA COMMITS TO
WORKERS AND LAW ABIDING
EMPLOYERS THAT IF THEY INVEST
THEIR TIME BODY AND MIND IN OUR
ECONOMIES THEY SHALL DO SO
UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS AND IF
THOSE CONDITIONS ARE NOT MET.
CALIFORNIA WILL DEFEND THEIR
BASIC RIGHT. ORIGINS OF THIS
CONTRACT WAS GROUNDED IN ME BY
WITNESS SEE MY FATHER WORKS
THREE JOBS AND MY MOTHER TO
JOBS TO PROVIDE FOR OUR FAMILY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN CHECKS
BOUNCE WAGES ARE STOLEN
RETALIATION OCCURS OR YOU
EXPERIENCE AN UNINSURED
EMPLOYER PEOPLE ARE TRAUMATIZED
FAMILIES ARE DEVASTATED. THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE IS
A FIRST RESPONDER TO THESE
TRAGIC REALITY. THESE CASES
FILED WITH MY OFFICE YOU NOT
ONLY REPRESENT LEGAL DISPUTES
BUT A VIOLATION OF CALIFORNIA
SOCIAL CONTRACT THAT IS THE
BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY. NOW IS
CALIFORNIANS FACED AN
UNPRECEDENTED PANDEMIC ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION AND A MOVEMENT THAT
HAS FORCED US TO RECKON WITH IN
THIS REGIONAL RACES. THAT
SOCIAL CONTRACT IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN. FOR TWENTY
YEARS THIS AGENCY WAS MY
BIGGEST PARTNER I LED A FIGHT
TO ELIMINATE UNFAIR COMPETITION
IN THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY I
LEARNED THAT EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT CANNOT BE ACHIEVED
BY WORKERS A LOAN OR A SINGLE
EMPLOYER. ALL STAKEHOLDERS
WORKERS EMPLOYERS INDUSTRY
LEADERS COMMUNITY GROUPS AND
GOVERNMENT NEED TO BE ENGAGED
TO ACHIEVE SUSTAINABLE
COMPLIANCE. SUCCESSFUL
ENFORCEMENT HAS THREE
COMPONENTS PROACTIVE EDUCATION
TIMELY ENGAGEMENT AND
CONSISTENT APPLICATION OF LAW.
COMPONENTS MUST BE BUILT IN OUR
REGULAR OPERATIONS SO THAT
EVERY ENFORCEMENT UP HOLD
CALIFORNIA SOCIAL CONTRACT FOR
BOTH WORKERS AND LAW ABIDING
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR ECONOMY. AS
LABOR COMMISSIONER EACH DAY I'M
WORK TO UPHOLD THE SOCIAL
CONTRACT FOR CALIFORNIA'S WORK
AND IT'S EMPLOYERS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I THINK WE WILL SEE IF MS BATES
WOULD LIKE TO START SENATOR ARE
YOU THERE. I AM WELCOME GOOD TO
SEE YOU. AGAIN TO BE HERE AT
LEAST A ON THE OF THIS GREAT
ANYWAY I WISH I COULD BE THERE
IN PERSON BUT- BOB LET ME START
WITH THE CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU. GARCIA FOR THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT APPOINTMENTS AND OUR-
IDEA FIRST AND FOREMOST ON
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO PUBLIC. REPRESENTATION VERY
COMPREHENSIVE AND SHE TOLD YOUR
PASSION FOR THE NEW JOB YOU'RE
YOU'RE TAKING ON A ACTUALLY
BEEN OUT AND ABOUT A YEAR I'M
LOOKING OUT THOUGH THE RIGHT
NUMBERS HERE. I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONFRONT SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE VERY
SIGNIFICANT IN MY DISTRICT SO
LET ME ASK YOU A FEW QUESTIONS
ON THOSE IT HAS TO DO NUMBER
ONE WITH THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR LOW. IN THE RIGHT.
YEAH ON WELL ACTION AFTER AND
STARTING WITH THE FIVE A QUICK
QUESTION THERE HAS BEEN COULD.
OVER THE BILL TO BUSINESS OUR-
AND WHETHER THOSE ARE. ARE
CERTAINLY AFFECTED BY EIGHTY
FIVE AND I THINK THAT CHAMBER
IT HAPPENED. THEY ALSO BOTH OF
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURE TO TAKE
A LOOK AT GOALS ARE TO SEE IF
WE CAN GET SOME CLARITY SO. HOW
IS YOUR OFFICE CURRENTLY
VIEWING THE BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS TRANSACTIONS. ARE
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S BETWEEN TWO
SOLE PROPRIETORSHIP
PROPRIETORSHIPS. THANK YOU
SENATOR. AB FIVE IS A VERY-
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND AS A NEW PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WE ARE EVALUATING
IT CAREFULLY- WE ARE OUR JOB IS
TO ENFORCE THE LAW. AND WE ARE
APPLYING THAT STATUTE AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT. OUR OFFICE IT
CAN BE MADE AVAILABLE TO ASSIST
YOU- ANTI ADMINISTRATION TO
EVALUATE PROVIDE YOU WITH
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE IN FOR ME
AND ASK ABOUT YOU EIGHT.
REFORMS THAT YOU MAY BE
CONSIDERED. THANK YOU FOR THAT
BUT I THINK GOING FORWARD I'M
GOING TO ASK IF YOU WANT TO A
GOT A LITTLE MORE TIME AND I'LL
CLEAR IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
HERE SOLD OUT. THERE'S
CONSISTENCY IN THE APPLICATION
OF AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE
THERE'S SOME CONFUSION AND
UNCERTAINTY CERTAINLY SO. JUST
ASK ANY AND YOU'RE GOING
FORWARD ON YOUR TO DO LIST IF
YOU'LL TAKE ANOTHER LITTLE
LONGER HARDER LOOK AT BECAUSE
WE CAN SHOW YOU TO GET A
RESPONSE FROM OUR IN REMEMBER
SANTA. YEAH IT WILL MAKE TO AN
ATTORNEY HARM KIND OF IN TAKE
ON IT SO I THINK SOMETHING
THAT'S MORE ABSOLUTE IN HOW YOU
APPROACH IT AS VERY STRONG
GUIDANCE LET'S SAY WOULD BE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL ON THE- THE
CARGO LAWSUITS CERTAINLY DURING
THE COLD BEARD WE KNOW THAT OUR
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN REALLY
REALLY CHALLENGED IN BEATING.
ALL LABOR LAWS. ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU- ISSUES COME FORWARD IN
OPERATE AS AN ESSENTIAL OR NON
ESSENTIAL BUSINESS. SO I'M WILL
BE NATURAL WE'RE THINKING IN
THE LABOR DEPARTMENT ABOUT SOME
REFORMS THAT MIGHT BE AYE
NISHIDA. AT LEAST ON DURING
THIS PANDEMIC AND CERTAINLY
GOING FORWARD. THAT WE HAVE ON
YOU GIVING EMPLOYER SOME
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE. VIOLATIONS
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN ESPECIALLY
DURING COLD BEEN UNINTENTIONAL
ARE WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT ON
THAT. THANK YOU SENATOR AND
BEFORE I GO TO THE POP THE
QUESTION LET ME ADD I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU THAT
IT IS ABSOLUTELY IMPERATIVE
THAT WE ARE CONSISTENT IN OUR
APPLICATION OF LAW. AND WE HAVE
WORKED IN COORDINATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYERS GET ONE ANSWER FROM
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SO I WOULD
REFER YOUR CONSTITUENTS TO OUR
AB FIVE PORTAL. AND MY TEAM CAN
BE MADE AVAILABLE TO HELP THEM
BEST UNDERSTAND THEIR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THAT TATUTE
AND WE'LL HAVE BEEN PART OF THE
OUTRAGE THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
WITH COLIN WE HAVE AN YEAR.
JEAN EVERY CALIFORNIAN OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN AND ONE OF THE PRIMARY
GOALS OF THAT OUTREACH CAMPAIGN
IS TO BUILD A BUSINESS. EACH
BROWN. WE HAVE TO A MUCH JOB OF
THE- EMPLOYERS NOT ONLY IN
RESPECTS THE DEFENSE OF
ALLEGATIONS BEING MADE AGAINST
THEM BUT TO HELP THEM UNDER.
THAT WE- FOR RESPONSE BUSINESS
IT IS OUR STATUTORY OBLIGATION
TO ELIMINATE UNFAIR COMPETITION
SO WE WANT TO BE A RESOURCE FOR
THEM AS THEY STRUGGLE WITH
THESE REALITIES I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT IT IS SUFFICIENT
FOR US TO SAY HERE'S THE LONG
NOW FOLLOW WITH. I STRUGGLED
WITH EMPLOYERS JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY FOR TWENTY YEARS IT
TAKES SOME TIME IT TAKES SME
UNDERSTANDING SOME ADJUSTMENTS
TRY DIFFERENT WAYS TO SEE GIVEN
THE ROLE OF THE COMPANY WHAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO AND PART OF
OUR- BUSINESS ENGAGE. THIS SO
WITH LOVE TO FOLLOW WITH OUR
OFFICE SINCE IF WE COULD DO A
WEBER ARE FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS
THE BETTER HELP THEM UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR OBLIGATIONS ARE
UNDER EIGHTY FIVE. WELL WHAT.
ABOUT THAT'S WONDERFUL THE
HEARING NANO GOING OUT AND YOU
NEED INTERACTION THAT
APPRECIATE THAT- CERTAINLY
ABSOLUTELY. AND I APOLOGIZE
SENATOR WOULD YOU REMIND ME
YOUR QUESTION ON WHICH RESPECTS
TO POPULAR. IT IS WHETHER OF
THEIRS REFORMS THAT MIGHT BE IN
THE RIGHT NOW FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN CHALLENGED THOSE
BUSINESS THOSE CHALLENGED WITH
YOU KNOW THE ON AGAIN OFF AGAIN
ON AGAIN NOW CENTRAL OR
NONESSENTIAL. OUR RESPONSE IN
THESE- WITH A POTENTIAL FOR-
YOU KNOW UNINTENTIONAL. ARE
VIOLATING OR BEING ON THE WRONG
SIDE OF THE LABOR LAUNDRY
CHALLENGE. THERE CAN BE ABA THE
VIEWS THAT THE WOULD TO BE ABLE
TO. WRAPPED WITHOUT HAVING SOME
SORT OF FINE OR ACTION TAKEN
AGAINST THEM I GUESS THE WOULD
BE SAYING. A WHICH HOW. THANK
YOU ARE WOULD BE THERE SO THAT
THEY WOULDN'T BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE DURING THIS
PARTICULAR TIME IF THEY WERE TO
REMEDIATE IMMEDIATELY WHATEVER
THE VIOLATION OB. ACTUALLY
OCCUR. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
RESTATING THAT QUESTION- WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO DO MORE WHEN
IT COMES TO PAGA AND IN HOW WE
ENGAGE EMPLOYERS I HAD MET THE
ADMINISTRATION- LATE LAST YEAR
AND EVALUATED THE NEEDS TO HAVE
INFORMATION ON ALL SPECIFICALLY
FOR EMPLOYER HIGHLIGHTING SOME
OF THE BEST PRACTICE IT IS AN
ABSOLUTELY HIGH. YOUR POINT THE
OPTION. WORK THAT AVAILABLE
THEM- SO WE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DELAYED IN EXECUTING THAT PLAN
BUT THAT IS- REFORM THAT I PLAN
TO IMPLEMENT AND I'M OPEN TO
HEAR FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND
FROM YOUR OFFICE OF ALL OTHER
REFORMS THAT WE SHOULD. WHEN IT
COMES TO THE LETTER OF THE LAW
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE TO IMPLEMENT
THAT LETTER- AS A LOT AS REGION
SO BUT AGAIN OUR TEAM IS
AVAILABLE WE DO HAVE A- UNIT OF
THE TROOPS WHO HAVE SPECIALIZED
EXPERIENCE- IN. EVALUATING THE
POPPY CASES- AND THEY CAN BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO BE A PARTNER
AS YOU EVALUATE ANY REFORM.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT THAT'S
GOOD NEWS AND GOING FORWARD OUR
OFFICE WILL BE VERY. IMPORTANT
INTO WORKING ALL WITH YOUR
OFFICE ON THOSE ISSUES THAT
COME TO OUR ATTENTION FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS LOOK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE WISH YOU THE BEST
ISSUE GO FORWARD IN THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES SENATOR
MINING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I WANT TO ADD MY
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU CHIEF
GARCIA BROWER AND THANK YOU FOR
NOW OVER A YEAR OF SERVICE- IN
YOUR POSITION AS CHIEF I ALSO
WANT TO. COME HERE PERRANCE
FAMILY AND THANK THEM FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE ROLE THEY
PLAYED IN BRINGING YOU TO THIS
CURRENT POSITION- CERTAINLY AN
INSPIRATIONAL. STORY I ENJOYED
OUR CONVERSATION THE OTHER DAY
AND I THINK FOR THE- BENEFIT OF
THE PANEL IN THE PUBLIC I JUST
HAD A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. ONE
HOW. HOW THE YOUR DIVISION IS
RESPONDING TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN FIRST AND FOREMOST
PROTECTING YOUR OWN EMPLOYEES
BUT HOW ARE YOU ABLE TO
CONTINUE WITH THE IMPORTANT IN
FORCE MEANT. ACTIONS THAT. THE
PROTECT WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO- ADD
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO OUR
DISCUSSION FROM YESTERDAY SO IN
GENERAL AS I PREVIOUSLY
COMMENTED. THE OUR AGENCY HAS
DONE A PRETTY PHENOMENAL JOB IN
TRANSITION NEEDS OF REMOTE
OPERATIONS WE HAVE- FIVE
HUNDRED OUTSTANDING. PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO OSE TO THE
CHALLENGE AND WE ACTUALLY THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND STRENGTH AND
IMPROVES THE PUBLIC SERVICE
THAT WE WERE PROVIDING WE PUT
MORE. OPERATORS ON THE LINE WE
ENGAGE IN. OUTREACH WE ARE
INDUCTED BIRD. CALL THIS THE
FIG OUT OF REACH EFFORTS OVER
THESE THREE MONTHS WHICH I
PARTICIPATED IN MORE THAN HALF
OF THOSE AND WE HAVE
PARTICULARLY BEEN FOCUSED IN
IDENTIFYING THOSE POPULATIONS
THAT DO NOT ALREADY HAVE AN
EXISTING PATHWAY TO BELIEVE
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE SO WE'RE
LOOKING TO. NOTE NEW
RELATIONSHIPS COMMUNITY TO
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS THAT WE
ARE AVAILABLE AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE. THIS IS
THE- WITH RESPECTS TO INFORM.
WE AS I MAY TO THE SENATOR TO
SENATOR BEATS WE HAVE A SHIFT
IN OUR PROTOCOLS CONSIDERING
THAT THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
THE STAND HOME ORDERS. AMANDA
THIS **** FOR BUSINESS
OPERATIONS AS IT IS FOR WORKERS
WHO WOULD JUST AND UNDERSTAND
THE WE ARE INCORPORATING A
PROACTIVE STEP BEFORE WE ENGAGE
IN ENFORCEMENT ACTION WE ARE
REACHING OUT TO LAWYERS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE NEW
RULES AND- KNOW THAT WE- RAIL.
ALL DIGEST THOSE AND ABOUT A
WEEK THEIR BUSINESS OPERATIONS
AND ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THAT THEY MAY HAVE. FOR THOSE
BUSINESSES WHERE WE HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO RESOLVE OUR TEAM HAS
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY IN
THESE THREE MONTHS WE'VE
ACTUALLY HUNDRED TWENTY.
EDUCATION THAT INCLUDE MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED VIOLATIONS
MAJORITY OF THEM BEING MINIMUM
WAGE AND OVERTIME OVER A BROAD
RANGE OF INDUSTRIES TOTALING
ABOUT SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN WAGE ASSESSMENTS. AND THEN
AS I ALSO COMMON WE ALSO BEEN
WORKING ON REACHING OUT TO
EMPLOYERS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND BECAUSE SOME OF
THE CALL WITH A TEXT THAT ARE A
LITTLE YOU ARE LABOR CODE STAFF
THAT ARE NOT COMMONLY. SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
UNDERSTAND THIS IN FACT IS AN
EXISTING LAW. HOW IT APPLIES TO
THEM AND TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT COMPREHENSIVE
ANSWER AND- I KNOW TODAY JULY
FIRST CALIFORNIA'S MINIMUM WAGE
RATE TO INCREASE ON DEPENDING
ON THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES-
THAT AN EMPLOYER HAS. AND
HOPEFULLY THAT INFORMATION IS
BEING COMMUNICATED MY FINAL
QUESTION FOR YOU CHIEF IS-
RELATED TO H. TO A GUEST
WORKERS. OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
BEING BROUGHT INTO FARMS. IN
DAIRY SO CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR.
WELL THAT'S A FEDERAL PROGRAM
THEY ARE PROTECTED BY
CALIFORNIA LABOR LAWS INCLUDING
WAGE RATES OVER TIME IT CETERA.
THIS IS HOW IT IS THE DIVISION
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OR ENFORCE
THE RIGHTS OF THAT VERY
SUSCEPTIBLE GUEST WORKER
POPULATION SUSCEPTIBLE I MEAN
IN THE SENSE. THEY'RE BROUGHT
NEXT TO GO FOR THE MOST PART
HOUSED IN EMPLOYER HOUSING
OFTEN WITHOUT A LOT OF
COMMUNICATION WITH THE OUTSIDE
WORLD IS THERE ANYTHING THE
DIVISION DOES TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS THE WAGE. PULLS IT
CENTRO OVERTIME PAY PER GUEST
WORKERS. THANK YOU SENATOR AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND TREMENDOUS- WORK THAT
YOU'VE INVESTED IN INCREASING
PROTECTIONS AND AWARENESS IN
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY I
SHARE YOUR CONCERN AND OUR
OFFICE DOES HAVE SEVERAL
EFFORTS OF THAT I'D LIKE TO
SHARE ONE IS WE HAVE A
STRATEGIC ENFORCEMENT PROJECT
THAT WAS INITIATED BY SECRETARY
SUIT AS LABOR COMMISSIONER. AND
WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH AGRICULTURAL-
ADVOCATES TO ENGAGE. CASE ONLY
A YOUR COMMENT TO I'M SORRY
THAT NOT ALL EXPO A
EXPLOITATION BUT ALSO- FAIR
COMPETITION WE'RE LOOKING TO
GET OUT THOSE LARGE PIECES THAT
HAVE SYSTEMIC VIOLATIONS SO WE
CONTINUE TO BE FOCUSED IN THAT
AREA WITH RESPECT SPECIFICALLY
TO THE GUEST WORKERS IT'S A
VERY- CHALLENGING STRUCTURE AND
SO WHAT WE'VE ACTUALLY DONE IS
WE'VE INITIATED AN EFFORT WITH
DD AS YOU WELL KNOW EDT. HOUSE
A- STRUCTURE ROLE- WITH THESE
JOB OFFERS AND THESE- WORKERS
THAT ARE BROUGHT IT AND WE ARE
EVALUATING WITH THEM HOW IT IS
WE CAN SO WE CAN MAX. OUR
EFFORTS TOGETHER AND THAT WE
CAN GET BETTER ACCESS TO BILLS
WORKERS- AND THOSE EMPLOYERS
AND THE THIRD PIECE OF IT IS
THEY HAVE A MIGRANTS- MONITOR
PROGRAM. WHICH WERE LOOKING TO
REALLY ATTACH OURSELVES TO- AND
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
WORKERS WITH RELEVANT
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR WORK.
AND HOW TO GET ACCESS TO US IN
ONE OF THE BRIDGES AS YOU WELL
KNOW IN THESE ROLE COMMUNITIES
IS. FINDING WHERE OUR OFFICES
SO MY HOPE IS THAT BY US
REACHING OUT TO EDT AND
PARTNERING WITH THEM WE WILL BE
ABLE TO GO OUT WITH THEIR
MIGRANT MONITORS- AT. SHOW UP
AT THEIR OFFICE AND WHATEVER IS
CONDUCIVE TO THE WORKERS BRING
UP NATION. THE LAST PIECE WANT
TO SHARE THAT IN PARTICULAR.
FARMWORKERS ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WE HAVE A FOCUSED
EFFORT. PART PARTY CHIEF
CALIFORNIA. EVERY MONTH WE WERE.
AT THE SONORA WHICH NO SPEAKS
TO DIE AS WELL ASK GRANTED WE
ALSO A ROB OLD FOR MEN OUT
WHERE WE HAVE HAS A GLOBAL
REACH IN THERE. AND LASTLY
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH SOME
POOR PARTNERS- LIKE SELECT THE
LEGAL CENTER- ALSO THE
COALITION OF LOW WAGE IMMIGRANT
WORKERS ADVOCATES TO PROVIDE
REGULAR NO YOU'RE RIGHT
SEMINARS- SO THAT WE CAN GET A
BROADER RANGE- IMPACT A BROADER
AUDIENCE OF WORKERS AND THE
SEMINARS HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN IN
SPANISH. OUR PRIMARY AUDIENCE
HUSBAND TO REACH DIRECTLY OF
SPANISH SPEAKING WORKERS. WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
AND JUST AGAIN WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YEARS OF LEADERSHIP
SEEKING TO ENFORCE PROTECTIVE
LAWS IN A- I THINK YOU'RE THE-
RIGHT PERSON AT THE RIGHT TIME
SO WELCOME ABOARD AND THANKS
FOR A YEAR OF LEADERSHIP
ALREADY THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING LAW TO
THE VICE CHAIRMAN SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CHIEF
CHRIS HERE BROWN
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
EMPLOYMENT AND- YOUR- FAITHFUL
PUBLIC SERVICE SAY YOU'VE DONE-
CENTER BEATS COVERED A LOT OF
THE AREAS THAT I WANTED TO
COVER- SO I THINK I THINK
PROBABLY ONLY HAVE ONE QUESTION
FOR YOU YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
OPENING WHICH I TOLD AGREE WITH
HIS EDUCATION GET MEN MEN EQUAL
APPLICATION OF THE LAW. AND SO
AB FIVE BE- TOOK AFFECTED IN IN
JANUARY SOME JUST INTEREST IN
WHAT KIND OF STEPS YOU'VE TAKEN
TO EDUCATE EMPLOYERS AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR ABOUT A.
B. FIVE TEST BE AS CENTER BATES
MENTIONED THERE'S TO BE ABLE TO
CONFIRM NOW THAT- OBVIOUSLY WE
WANT EVERYBODY. COMPLY ANTS.
THANK YOU SIR. YEAH AS I USED
WORKER ACCORDING WITH THE A AND
LABOR AGENCY TO PROVIDE THE AB
FIVE PORTAL SO THAT. RECEIVE
INFORMATION. AND AS I COMMENTED
WE HAVE TO DO A LOT MORE TO
CREATE SPACE BECAUSE EVEN YOU
GO INTO A PORTAL AND THERE'S A
LOT OF RAPPING- BUT YOU STILL
NEED TO DIGEST THAT AND UNDER
STAND IT AND PEOPLE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE INCREASED
OBLIGATIONS AND THE SHIP THAT
IT CREATES FOR THEIR BUSINESSES
SO WE ARE LOOKING FOR EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE IN. ONE
OF OUR EXIT IN OPPORTUNITIES IS
WE HAVE A LOT. OUR WITH THE D.
WE PROVIDE A FULL SEMINARS
EMPLOYERS ON JUST THE NOT
SIMPLE HOW TO PAY PEOPLE
PROPERLY AND WHAT ARE THE RIVER
FOURTEEN MECHANISMS WE HAVE
TAKEN THAT OPPORTUNITY-
INSERTED IN THERE AB. FIVE
INFORMATION AS WELL AS- THE
RELATED. INFORMATION ANDWE
ACTUALLY INCREASED OUR OUTREACH
ON THE SEMINARS. SOCIAL STREETS
AND DIGITAL. AND OUR FIRST
SEMINAR IN APRIL WE ONLY HAD
THIRTY FOUR EMPLOYERS IN OUR
LAST SOMEONE ARE WHICH WAS JUST
LAST WEEK WE HAD ON HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN EMPLOYERS PARTICIPATE
SO I AM. HOPEFUL THAT THIS IS
AN ALBUM OF AND YOU FOR YOUR
STILL COMPARABLE IN AND WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE LOOKING TO
CONTINUE TO GROW. AND WE HAVE.
SAID BRUCE THAT ANOTHER WAY
WE'RE LOOKING TO ENGAGE
EMPLOYERS IS WE HAVE- ENGAGE
WITH EIGHTY P. AS I MENTIONED
TO PROVIDE NO YOU'RE RIGHT
SEMINARS AND WE'RE PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS CLIENTS. SO WE WILL BE
DEVELOPING A WEAPON ARE THAT
WILL BE PRE RECORDED AND
AVAILABLE FOR THEIR CLIENTS. TO
REVIEW AND AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING
TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE WITHIN OUR
AGENCY AS OPPOSED TO AN EMAIL
OR AND NUMBER OF THAT READS A
LOT BUT WE WILL BE IDENTIFYING
IT IS ENGAGEMENT PROGRAM STAFF
WHO THAT WILL BE ONE OF THEIR
PRIMARY FOCUSES IS. THE RISK.
AND THESE. UNDERSTAND THE
STRUGGLES AND BRING BACK TO US
IN WHICH WE WILL SHARE WITH YOU
ANY OBSERVATIONS AND TRENDS
THAT WERE SEE. GREAT THANK YOU
FOR THAT- NO YOU HAVE MADE AN
OFFER TO SENATOR BASE TO DO A
WOMEN- WEB IN OUR WHEN EIGHTY
FIVE WITH HER CONSTITUENTS I
WAS JUST WONDERING THAT WOULD
BE EXTENDED THAT COURTESY TO ME
AS WELL. ABSOLUTELY NOT. FOLLOW
UP AT SEVEN AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SURVIVOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR ROTH
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM-
ACTUALLY NO QUESTIONS MADAM
CHIEF OF CONGRATULATIONS GO
HIGHLANDERS. THANK YOU. I
WONDERED IF THAT COME UP
SENATOR ROTH I'M I DON'T HAVE
QUESTIONS EITHER I THINK YOUR
ANSWER FOR COMPLETE IT'S VERY
CLEAR TO TELL THAT YOU ARE
REALLY PASSIONATE ABOUT THE
WORK THAT YOU DO ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE I WANT TO SAY YOU. OF
YOUR SERVICE AND- GONNA GO ON.
PUBLIC AND- HE WE'RE GONNA
START HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE- OF MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
OUR I WOULD DO A REMIND FOLKS
WE'RE GOING TO INSURE SO
DISTANCING SO. FOUR AND I DON'T
THINK THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN-
ONLY ONE PERSON AT A TIME AT
THE MICROPHONE BUT I SHOULD SAY
THESE THINGS. ANYONE IN THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OKAY
SEEING NONE WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY BECAUSE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE COVER ALL
THE BAY. ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
HE- ME MOVE OUR TO THE
TELECONFERENCE ONE. AND WELCOME
THE MODERATOR AND- ASK IF THERE
ARE PEOPLE WAITING OR IF YOU
CAN T. UP ANYONE WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ANYONE WHO
WILL INITIAL SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE SHOWING
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. MADAME
MODERATOR. MUCH I WE WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN A MOMENT. SO
WE WILL NOW GO TO- MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. FROM BACK THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE AS THEIR OWN IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE HERE
TO SPEAK IT IS IT SHOULD. OKAY
SEE DONE I WILL TAKE ROOM TO BE
FORTY. SEEING NO ONE THERE
STEPPING FORWARD TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION MADAM MODERATOR I'M
COMING BACK TO YOU TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE. ARE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE. AT THIS TIME.
AND THERE'S NO ONE IN JUDICIAL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OBVIOUSLY ARE EVERYONE HAS BEEN
CONVINCED- AT THIS POINT LET ME
JUST GO TO MY COLLEAGUES AND
SEE IF SOMEONE WILL MAKE A
MOTION FOR MOVED. WITH SENATOR
ROTH THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I'M
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MY AYE MONNING I ROTH ARE
ROTH I WILL FIGHT LOOK I ATKINS
AYE ATKINS AYE THAT IS FOR TWO
ZERO AND I CONGRADULATIONS VERY
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER SEE
A BROWN. YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
SENATORS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE AND I WILL
ABSOLUTELY FOLLOW UP WITH EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU TO SEE HOW
WE CAN BETTER SERVE. YOU THANK
YOU. WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
GO TO THE NEXT TO MEMBERS ARE
REQUIRED TO APPEAR APPOINTMENTS
IN THIS IS THE AGRICULTURAL
LABOR RELATIONS BOARD AND WE
HAVE TO OUR APPOINTEES TODAY-
FORMER SENATOR- AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE HONORABLE ISIDORE
HALL THE THIRD AND MISTER RALPH
THE LIGHTS ALL WANNA SAY
WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU I'VE
NOTICED YOU PATIENT IN. I THE
ON THE LOT AND TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN- WITH INTRODUCTIONS FROM
OUR THE FORMER SENATOR. OUT
MISTER HALL AND IT WILL GO TO
MISTER LIGHTSTONE TO DO THE
SAME EACH OF YOU- IF YOU WANT
TO GIVE YOUR OPENING COMMENTS.
THANKS TO ANYONE. I AND AFTER
EACH OF YOU WILL TELL YOU BOTH
AT THE SAME TIME AFTER EACH OF
YOU HAD A CHANCE THE PRODUCE
TELLS A METACOMET WE WILL GO TO
MAKE OF THE CITY. AND SO ARE.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU ARE
SENATOR WELL. AND GO AND A BIG.
THANK YOU GOOD TO SEE YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT PRO TEM AND TO
ALL OF MY FORMER COLLEAGUES. SO
GOOD TO SEE ALL OF YOU- MINING
DATES WILL ROTH- MISS YOU ALL
AND I THINK YOU WILL FOR THE
GREAT WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING.
TO FIRST IF YOU WILL ALLOW ME
TO FOR STATE GOVERNMENT NEWS.
WHEN YOU MEET TWISTY EARN ONLY
LRB BUT ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR'S TEAM FOR ART WORK
THEY'RE DOING A MOVIE WHEN IT'S
FORWARD DURING SOME OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING TIMES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. ALSO THANK EACH OF
YOU AND YOUR NEIGHBORS FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS ADVOCATE.
BUSINESS YOUR THESE PRESS IT
TIMES IT HAS CLEARLY BEEN
ANONYMOUS SERVICE MEMBER OF THE
ARE. OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS
OBVIOUSLY THE WAR CONTINUES TO
DO THE WORK FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. OF THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA- HAS OBVIOUSLY AND
IT PRESENCE AT LEAST
FARMWORKERS FROM THOSE FROM THE
A RP AND TO THAT END WE HAVE
BEEN FUNCTIONING AND HAS.
FUNCTIONING WELL. DURING MY
TERM ON THE BOARD I HAVE WORKED
WITH MY FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS
COUNCIL TO ENSURE NUMEROUS WELL
RESEARCHED DECISIONS GENERAL
MOTORS COVERING MANY ISSUES
TWENTY FIVE DECISIONS. IN OUT
OF THE ARTERIES MISSION ON
PROMOTE JUSTICE FOR. WORKERS
THE WORST DECISIONS HAVE
GENERALLY WAS AT WORK
CHALLENGES. AND I FEEL. THE I
FEEL THAT AT BEEN FAIRLY THIS
INCORRECTLY CONSIDERED ALL HARD
WHO. WORKGROUP DIVORCES THE
HAVE PROVIDED INMONETARY SUCH
AS FACTORY WORK WHO WERE WRONG
DISH. IN ANY ROOM ARE IN FLOOR
UNIONS. RIGHT RESPONSE. UNDER A
L. A. YOU RECALL SENATORS LIKE
ME TO COMMIT TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU TO SIT RULES
COMMITTEE TO CONVENE STATE.
FEDERAL OR STATE EACH AND EVERY
DAY ONE OF THE MOST IMPACTED I
ATTENDED AS A REMEMBER THIS IS
IN THE FORMER BECAUSE SHE
RECORDS. IT WAS ON TO SEE SO
MANY. INDIVIDUALS GAS IN THE
EARLY HOURS OF THREE OF O'CLOCK
AND- UNDER. THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE SOLUTION A CAL. ACT IN.
THIS IS THE NATIONAL IN A IS
PROUD TO. PROTEST EACH AND
EVERY YEAR. MICHAEL. THIS TERM
RESUME OF THE- I WILL MAKE TO
THAT THE L. BEAT. THEIR
ACCESSIBLE POOL FOR FORMER.
BEGINS I AM A CULTURAL WE
RESOLVE THEIR JUST. ARE MY WORK
ON THE BOARD IT IS THAT I
REMAIN DE TO SEEN THAT THE
STATE WERE RIGHT STORE IN THE
ANSWER TIMES. IS THAT THE ONLY
IMPORTANCE THAT CASES BE THE
BOY OUR RESOLVE THE FISH LEE
AND IN PART ALL GOING TO WORK
TOWARDS THE GOAL FOR IN NEW
WAYS. FOR THE YEAR READER
PROVIDE CONCRETE EDUCATE OUR-
ON THE SO FOR BY THE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA GO TO-
MISTER LIGHTSTONE NOW THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
WAITING. AND FEEL FREE TO MAKE
ANY OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN
WE'LL- GO RIGHT FIRST. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO JAVAN SENATORS OF
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
MY WIFE EMILY PASTAS OF OUR
CHILDREN DANIEL AND SARA FOR
THEIR SUPPORT DROP MY CAREER.
NOW I'D LIKE TO THANK GOVERNOR
NEWSOME. FOR THE GREAT HONOR
APPOINTMENTS I LIKE TO THINK
THEY ARE THE STAFF OF MY FELLOW
BOARD MEMBERS INCLUDING ALL.
THEIR SUPPORT AND ONGOING
IMPLEMENTED ALOFT IT'S A GREAT
HONOR TO SERVE ON THE A RP
WHICH PROTEST I'M SURE. FARM.
GO SHAPE THE TERMS IN
CONDITIONS OF THEIR- THEY ARE
AWAY WAS THE FOR LAW ITS FIVE
IN THE- AND IT'S- A MODEL THE
UNITED STATES. MY BACKGROUND OF
MY CREW BACKGROUND I BELIEVE
WILL SERVE ME WELL IN THIS
POSITION. BUT DURING MY CAREER
NO TRUST ME I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE. FOR
MANY YEARS IS SOME COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT.
CALIFORNIA THE GENERAL OFFICE.
THEIR WORKFORCE AT AGENCY. AS A
BOARD MEMBER OF WHEN INSURANCE
APPEALS BOARD. IT IS THE
POSITION. I LEARNED ABOUT THE
ISSUES AFFECTING CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKERS **** SURE. IF
YOU'RE LABOR AT. PRO BOARD
MEMBER AS A BOARD MEMBER I'M
WORK TO AND THAT FORTY SHE'S
BEAR BUT LEGAL SOUND AND WHILE
WE JUST I THINK THE FORCE
FEDERAL SAID BE FOUND IN
OPINIONS OF THE HIGHER. THE
REVIEW OUR DECISIONS AND I WILL
ALSO WORK TO STRENGTHEN THE
BOARDS PROCESSES EXPEDITE
RESOLUTION OF DISPUTES SURE THE
BOARD'S DECISIONS ARE
IMPLEMENTED AND EDUCATE FORM
PRESENTS STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT THE
WALL. SERVING ON THIS BOARD IS
A GREAT HONOR AND RESPONSE
MELODY I'M EXCITED TO SHARE
THIS HONOR RESPONSIBILITY WAS
CENTER ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES AND
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND HOPE YOU
RECOMMEND MY CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU MISTER LIGHTS FOUND.
OUT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED AND I'M GONNA START
AGAIN WITH SENATOR BATES WHO IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATOR
BATES ARE YOU. PREPARED TO MAKE
COMMENTS QUESTIONS GO AHEAD.
YES I'M HERE HAND CAN YOU HEAR
ME I HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK OUT
THAT I. YES CAN I AM YOUR SIGN
I NEEDED BACKSTOPS WELL THANK
YOU ARE BOTH GENTLEMEN
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT. SENATOR ALL BOARD
MEMBER CARL AND BOARD MEMBER ON.
HI ACTUAL THE PREFONTAINE'S
AND- THAT YOU HAVE. COULD YOU
ARE REALLY GO TO THE HEART OF
MICHAEL THAT SOUNDS ME COMPARED
TO A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
ESPECIALLY ARE YOU'RE HEARING
ME UP ON CENTER THERE WAS A LOT
OF ANIMOSITY. NOT SEEN. BETWEEN
OUR FULL. PERCENT THE INFO. ARE
WHETHER THEY WERE GETTING OUT
THEIR VIEWS HEARD WHETHER
HEARINGS WERE FAIR IN TERMS OF
THE BALANCE OF THE RIGHTS OF
FARMWORKERS. HOUSE TO NEED LIKE
YOUR REACH IS MAKING A SO I'M
GOING TO ACTUALLY GET. ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE ISSUE DECIDED NOW.
AND PROBABLY A LITTLE MORE
PEACE IN THE VALLEY IF I CAN
USE THAT TERM. FLORA YOU KNOW
THE VERY IMPORTANT WORK THAT
THEY DO BOTH SIDES WE CANNOT DO
WITHOUT EITHER. OUR OUR GROWERS
SO WHERE ARE FARMWORKERS
SUBSTANTIAL TO THE BASKET
CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA THE
NATION. THAT OUR HELP ME
UNDERSTAND THE BOB. THERE THERE
HAS BEEN CONFUSION OVER WHERE
THOSE ARE FILED SINCE THERE ARE.
TIME HE LAW. THERE ARE THERE
ARE TO GET THE HAS BEEN
RESOLVED I BOBBY ON SOME I IN
THE BACKGROUND DOUBT THERE WAS
CONFUSION OVER WHERE ONE FINAL
A GRIEVANCE AND WHO ACTUALLY BE
ONLY SAW. SO EITHER ONE AND
WANTS TO RESPOND TO THAT KIND
OF THE HEART OF MY QUESTION.
YES SIR YOU. GO AHEAD SENATOR
HALL WILL IT TAKE. THANK YOU
YES- GRIEVANCES ARE INITIATED
IN OUR DISTRICT OFFICE. AND
THEN MOVED OVER TO OUR GENERAL
COUNSEL. AND IS. THE GENERAL
COUNSEL SITES REALITIES A
SUCCESSFUL REVOLUTION
RESOLUTION CANNOT BE OUR AROUND
THEN WILL MOVE THAT OVER TO THE
BOARD SO NORMALLY IS FROM THE
DISTRICT TO THE GENERAL. YOU
KNOW OUR TIMES WORLD ALL THE
TIME BUT IN REALITY THERE IS A
FIREWALL. BETWEEN THE GENERAL
COUNSEL AND THE BOARD UPLAND
HILL THE GENERAL COUNSEL SINCE
MAY ALL OF US AND I ALSO SAY.
BASED THANK YOU FOR YOUR FIRST
DATE. IN THAT YES WE DID THE
WORK NAY I NEED. TO YOU AND-
ENTIRE SENATE- THAT I WOULD GO
OUT AND MEET WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO EDUCATE
COLLAPSE. WERE NECESSARY AND TO
THE FACT THAT POINT. WE HAVE
GREAT FOR. WE VISITED OVER
NINE. AND MET WITH DOZENS AND
DOZENS AND OF ACROSS THE STATE.
EIGHT AND ASSIST I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT SENATOR ON TO
THAT POINTS OUT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO BRING GREAT ALL. AND
AGAIN. YOU AVE YOU FOR YOUR AND
TO THE- EXTRA EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT POSITIONS THAT YOU
NOW HAVE. YOU NOT IN A VERY
CRITICAL INDUSTRY SO OB I WISH
EL GOING FORWARD IN THE
CONFIRMATION I'LL CRY DO A
LITTLE MORE. REACH CELL. I
NINETY COMMUTING NO.
PARTICIPATE REMOTE SO BUT I DO
WISH YOU WELL IN I PRESSED WITH
YOUR PRE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YES. THANK YOU SENATOR LET ME
JUST DOUBLE CHECK OUR MISTER
LEISTON WAS THERE ANYTHING YOU
WANTED TO ADD TO THAT RESPONSE
YOU YOU DON'T NEED TO BUT YOU
CERTAINLY. JUST I WAS SAID ONE
FOOTNOTE I THINK. HALL SAID
RISK PRACTICE THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ADD IS THAT IF IT'S A IF.
IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL ALL OF HAS A
WE CLAIM THEY WOULD FILE THAT
NOR WITH THE LABOR COMMISSION.
IN OUR PREVIOUS APPOINTEE THEY
HAVE A WILL CLAIM PROCESS. ARE
JURISDICTION INVOLVES KIND OF
AND I'M NOT SURE WHICH REST
WHEN WORKERS. I AGREE. IT
TOGETHER THAT THEY ACTUALLY
BECOME AN UNFAIR LATE LABOR
PRACTICE CHARGE WHICH CENTER
ALWAYS DESCRIBED. THANK YOU DAD
OF CLARIFY IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER BATES I SENATOR OFF
LET ME START WITH YOU THIS.
THANK YOU MA'AM PRO TEM
ACTUALLY HAVE A NEW GERMAN CA.
VERY MUCH. CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I ACTUALLY HAVE NO
CLUE NO QUESTIONS EITHER
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND RE APPOINTMENT.
I SMOOTHER SAILING FOR YOU TIME
SENATOR HARKIN AND LAST TIME
AND AGAIN THAT WOULD BE TO YOU
IN THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE. I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE- GO AHEAD
YOU'RE GOING TO HELP WITH. IT
ALSO. YOU COME OFF THE SENATE
AND YOU HAVE TO. YOU HAVE TO GO
BACK INTO THE CAN BE REACHED
OUT TO REESTABLISH YOURSELF.
MAY NOT HAVE KNOWN THE WORD YOU
GET WHAT YOU REMEMBER OF THE
REGISTER. SO I HOPE THAT NONE
OF YOU EVER HAVE TO DEAL WITH
EVER COMING OFF THIS- GOOD. GOD
HEARS YEAH I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO VOTING FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU MAKING. THANK YOU AND
JUST AS I MOVED TO A SENATOR
MONEY LET ME ADD SUGGEST AS MY-
INCREDIBLE ASSISTANT REMINDED
ME THAT REMOTELY IF GO AHEAD
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU WANT TO
ANSWER SINCE WE HAVE TWO
APPOINTEES ON. THE YOU CAN NOT
A TEST. FOUR EIGHTY. AND RAISE
YOUR HAND IF YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO THE QUESTION OUR
COMMENT THAT- SENATOR RACES SO
SENATOR MONNING LET ME YEAH GO
TO YOU. THANK YOU MAY SHARE I
ALSO WANT. OFFER MY
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANKS TO
BOTH OF YOU- TO CONGRATULATE
YOU ON YOUR REAPPOINTMENT
SENATOR HALL IN AND MISTER
LIGHTSTONE ON YOUR APPOINTMENT
IN YOUR SERVICE THROUGH THE
YEARS IN DIFFERENT. AGENCIES
SERVING LEGEND- SERVING THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- IN AS YOU
DESCRIBED IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT- WELL EQUIPPED TO
PERCENT- THE PEOPLE OF OUR NHà
ON THE BOOK. A QUESTION AND I
ALSO JUST WANT TO IGNORE SENATE
HALLS. FULL FILLING THE
COMMITMENT OF THE OUT REACH- I
THINK EVIDENCE BY OF. THIS IS A
VERY DIFFERENT HEARING THAN THE
FIRST ONE THAT WE HAD AFTER
YOUR FIRST APPOINTED AND I
THINK A TRIBUTE TO YOUR
COMMITMENT TO US OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE TO DO
THAT OUT REACHED THE
STAKEHOLDERS SO I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IN Q. YOU TALK
ABOUT. ON ON AN ALL OUT MAYBE
BOTH OF YOU TO RE. IN MAYBE
SENATOR HALL FOR FOLLOWED BY.
MR LIGHT STONE. THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IS GROWING IN
CALIFORNIA LITERALLY THERE'S
OVERSIGHT AT THE RETAIL LEVEL
OF- DISPENSARIES BUT THE
GROWING ASPECT HAPPENING AROUND
THE STATE I BELIEVE IS UNDER
THE PURVIEW OF THE ALE ARE
BEING TRACK OF YOUR
JURISDICTION ON LABOR ISSUES
ORGANIZING ISSUES I WONDER IF
YOU MIGHT EACH IN YOUR OWN
WORDS JUST. OFFER HOW THE HELL
ARE BE. IS TRANSITIONING TO
INCLUDE THAT IN YOUR
JURISDICTIONAL OVERSIGHT THANK
YOU. YES THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL- AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE WE HAVE A
CANNABIS SPECIALISTS NEXT
MEETING REGULAR- WHICH IS THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS INDUSTRY.
ADVISING THEM OF THEIR RIGHTS
AS EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS- AS
YOU KNOW FOR A SIMPLE REASON
EMPLOYERS IN THIS INDUSTRY SOME
HAVE OPERATED FOR MANY YEARS.
UNDERGROUND AND THEY ARE
UNAWARE AND SOMEONE LEE READ
AND STEEL OF THEIR RIGHTS AS A
BONAFIDE EAGLE OPERATOR. GOING
A LOT WORK IN IN AS I AS I
EARLIER YOU KNOW EDUCATE COLLAB
AND ASSIST AND AS LONG AS WE TO
DO THAT WE WILL- HE TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD TRUST WITH INDUSTRY
THAT WE SERVE OUR NESTLED SIGN
EMPLOYEES INSULTED ADDING OUR
OUR CANNABIS REP IS NEEDING
RIGHT WITH OUR- AND- WE MEAN IT
THE STATE WATER SO. EQUAL.
FIRST RAP. I STAKEHOLDERS ARE
ONCE ON OTHER SIDE OF THIS-
CALLED NINETEEN BUT LET ME SAY
THAT WE ARE REPRESENTED IS
DOING GREAT WORK AND ONCE WE
COMPLETE SOME OF THE REPORTS
THAT ALLEN. DOES YOUR BILL. THE
RULE COMMITTEE. LIKE HER LIFE
SOME GO AHEAD. YEAH OF I AGREE
WITH ALL OF THAT I WOULD JUST
TO ADD SAID- BOARD MEMBER
BROUGHT PREVIOUSLY WORKED FOR
THE TEAMSTERS UNION ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE SEVERAL UNIONS ARE
INVOLVED IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AND- HELP US ORGAN.
YES ORGANIZED THE INFORMATION
HANDLES AND THEIR SESSIONS THAT
THE GENERAL HALL REFERRED TO
THE- THE WE HAVE ONE IN
CATHEDRAL CITY IN DECEMBER AND
FOR SOME VARIOUS EMPLOYERS AN
INDUSTRY GROUPS AS WELL AS THE
LABOR GROUPS THAT. AND AS
GENERAL AS WE'RE GOING TO BE
HAVING MORE OF THOSE AND WE
PUSH BACK HAVE EXPECTED THERE
WILL BE SOME MORE. ACTIONS IN
IN. AS FOR. THANK YOU FOR ALL
ARE VERY GOOD I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS- I WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE HERE I WANT TO THANK
BOTH OF YOU. YOU KNOW I. WAS
GONNA SAY IT'S THE BENEFIT OF
GOING TO LAST YOU DON'T HAVE TO
SAY THINGS WHICH WAS. IT WAS
QUITE A BIT I SIT QUESTION LAST
TIME AND I. SLATED TO. OUR
TWENTY THAT WAS UNDER. WAY I IN
THE INDUSTRY THAT CAUSED A LOT
OF CONSTERNATION AND BECAUSE-
THEY HAVE A LOT OF COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS AND CLEARLY. SOME
WORK HAS BEEN DONE THE AMP
ENVIRONMENT CHANGED- I THINK
THAT IS THE GOOD. LET ME AS WE
TO TEST. EXCEPT I WANT TO GIVE
A ROOM. FOR WISHING TO COMMENT
THE PHONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR
IS ON THE SCREEN AGAIN. AND THE
CODE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN FIVE
ZERO TWO ZERO ONE THREE. AND SO
WITH THAT WE WILL START WITH
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IN
SUPPORT. OKAY NO ONE STEPPING
FORWARD LET ME GO AHEAD AND GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY JUST TO
BIG BE COVERED THE BASES ANYONE
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATIONS
SEEING NO ROUTE ONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. LET ME GO AHEAD AND GO
NOW TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
AND WELCOME BACK AT MANTA
MODERATOR. AND SEE IF THERE ARE
WITNESSES WAITING ON THE LINE
IN SUPPORT. AND AS A REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE
NO ONE SHOWING SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THEN
WE WILL COME BACK INTO THE ROOM
OUR ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
MIGHT BE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
AGAIN I AM SEEING NO ONE
STEPPING FORWARD SO LET ME
COVER. THE BASE OF ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE THERE. SEEING NO
ONE IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MADAME MODERATOR
I WILL COME BACK TO YOU TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WAITING TO.
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN AT THE REMINDER
SHOW UP PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
FEEL AFTER TIME. AND I SHOW NO
ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION AT THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR YOUR JOB IS REALLY
TOUGH TODAY ARE. AND I PRE THAT
LET ME KNOCK ON WOOD AS I SAY
IT THAT THAT IS A SIGN OF OUR-
OF BY HOW WE LET THINGS TO GO
PEOPLE TO BE ARE NOT CONCERNED.
LET ME JUST CONFIRM WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WE DON'T NEED
TO SEPARATE THIS MOTION WE CAN
TAKE BOTH MISTER LIGHTSTONE AND
SENATOR HALL AT THE SAME TIME
I'M HAVE TAKEN I'D LIKE TO MOVE
TO. SENATOR PLAYING I FIRST ON
THE LIGHTS MOVE OUR- THE
NOMINATE OR THE FOR. MADAM
SECRETARY WE THE ROLL. MONNING
I ON IN I ROTH I'M ROTH I WILK
HI LOOK. ATKINS AYE ATKINS.
THAT IS BORDERS UNANIMOUS IN
TERMS OF MEMBERS. PRESENT SO
CAN. TO BOTH YOU THEY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBERS NAY YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE BOTH OF
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY I'M GONNA
TO A MALL AND SEE IF OUR STERN
I. NEEDS A BREAK AND- I
MAYFIELD ME OF WE NEED TO A
BREAK. YES OKAY WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE ABOUT A FIVE TO SEVEN
MINUTE BREAK WE WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU THANK YOU.
WELL.
FOR YOU NEXT WILL GO TO THE
APPOINTMENT OF THE THREE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LOTTERY COMMISSION THAT WOULD
BE- FAIR OF GREGORY EFFORT
KEITH THE MILLS AND PETER STERN
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING SO PATIENT I WAITING IN I
WANNA DO WHAT WE DID WITH THE
PRE OF WHICH IS ALLOW EACH OF
YOU. ARE I'M IT DO SURE THANK
YOU THAT MY BE OUR OUT WITH YOU
OR THAT YOU LIKE TO SEE POINT
IT AND THEN MAKE A OPENING
COMMENTS THAT YOU LIKE TO THE
NAME WILL GO RIGHT MEMBERS WE
WILL START WITH SHARE OUR GO TO
KEEP. AND THEN. AND SO BUT YOU
SAW. ARE YOU CAN HEAR ME OK
SURE CAN'T YOU ALL THANK VERY
MUCH AND TAKE YOU TIME
OPPORTUNITY JUST TO THIS RULES
JUST SELECT KNOW I'M OF YOUR
VOTE OF THE CAN SHERIFF OFFICE
AGAIN LIKE AND OF NAY EIGHTY. I
STATE WILL YOUR SOME THE SUN
WAS ABLE PROMOTE A THROUGH THE
RANKS OF ELECTED TWO THOUSAND
SIX TO CALL CENTER. NOW YOU
KNOW HOW MANY COUNTY SOME VERY.
AREAS. HELLO ARE ADJACENT
COUNTIES. AND I KNOW THAT
IMPROVED EDUCATION CAL REDUCE
CRIME RATES. AND ALSO. JOURNEYS
FOR GRADUATES. MY OPPORTUNITY
TO SERVE ON THE LOTTERY ALLOWS
ME. HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT ON THE
IMPROVE MY EDUCATION BY
MAXIMIZING. GROWTH THE FUNDS
PROVIDED TO EDUCATION. AND
CALIFORNIA'S THE GREATEST STATE
IN THIS NATION I FIND NO REASON
WHY WE SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE FINEST GOING TO OUR
YOUNG STUDENTS. WITH THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDS PROVIDED TO
THE EDGE EDUCATION BY LOTTERY.
WE CAN CONTRIBUTE AND CONTINUE
TO FIGHT THE NATIONAL
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IN THE
COUNTRY. ONE OF MY GOALS IS THE
RACE CALIFORNIA LOTTERY TO THE
NUMBER ONE LOTTERY IN THE
NATION. WHEN I STARTED WITH A
LOTTERY WE ARE FORCED HIGHEST
SELLING LOTTERY AND NOW WE ONLY
TRAIL NEW YORK AS NUMBER TWO.
MORE IMPORTANTLY WATERS
CONTRIBUTION JENNER EDUCATION
INCREASED FROM APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN. FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ELEVEN
AND TWELVE. TO ONE POINT EIGHT
DOLLARS AND OUR LAST AUDITED
YEAR OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETY. SO WE HOPE TO SUPPRESS
NEW YORK WITH THE EFFORTS OF A
GREAT STAFF WORKS ON A LOTTERY
TEAM. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO SERVE ON A
LOTTERY COMMISSION AND LOOK FOR
DENTURE ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I SHOULD POINT OUT SURE OF
IS A REAPPOINTMENT AND BY NEXT
WOULD BE MRS MILLER MS MILLS-
WELCOME AND DASH GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM HER TEN
SENATORS- GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY I. THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT COME BEFORE
YOU AND DISCUSS WILL PRESENT TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY
COMMISSION I WANT TO START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING KNOWS BETTER
SUPPORTED ME AT LEE INCLUDING
MY PARTNER THE LANI AND MANY
WONDERFUL FRIENDS AND MY
INCREDIBLE COLLEAGUES WHO ALL
WORKED TIRELESSLY. TO SUPPORT
OUR OVER TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STATE. WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- I'M HONORED
AND GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR
FOR APPOINTING ME TO THE
COMMISSION AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE MY BACK THE
NEXT GRAND SO A LOT OF. PHILIP
PROVIDE MENTAL. CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL. I'M MY OWN PASSION A
TWO. AT AT A VERY YOUNG AGE-
WITH THE INFLUENCE OF MY LATE
MOTHER IT WAS AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHER FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND I A COUPLE THAT
WITH MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
AND- AND PUBLIC EDUCATION THAT
INCLUDED. YOU KNOW K. WEALTH
UNITY COLLEGE AND MY STATE
UNIVERSE BE- AND WORKING FULL
TIME THROUGH COLLEGE SUPPORT
SOUTH. IT WAS REALLY THE
EXPERIENCES WHERE I CAME TO
UNDERSTAND THE TRUE POWER OF
PUBLIC EDUCATION AS A CRUCIAL
GATEWAY ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL THE
LADY. IS PASSIONATE TO MY WORK
WITH THE COMBINATION FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OR TO LEARN. AND I'LL EVERY.
SUNDAY THAT IN OUR SCHOOL. HELP
TO POSITIVELY IN. THE LIVES OF
OURS. SO I PUT INTO THE
COMMISSION REALLY TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY AFTER ME TO APPLY
MY NONPROFIT EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT EXPERIENCE- MY-
ACCOUNTING AND AUDITING
BACKGROUND AS A CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT AND MY DEEP
PASSION FOR EDUCATION. THE
SUPPORT THE LOTTERIES HER AND
MY SPENDING CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. THROUGH MY SHORT TERM-
ON THE COMMISSION OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS. SEVERAL
POTENTIAL. LOTTERY HOW THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER ENHANCE
ITS WORK TO FULFILL ITS ITS
MISSION AND I BY I'VE
IDENTIFIED THREE MAIN GOALS
THAT I WOULD PURSUE- IN MY ROLE
AS THE COMMISSIONER SO MY FIRST
GOAL IS TO ENSURE AND LET US ON
THE LOW MISSION AND MISSIONS
TRIP WILSHIRE THE ORGAN IN THE
MAXIMIZE AND- ALL REPUBLICANS
GEN. ON MY SECOND GOAL IS TO
WORK TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
PERCEPTION AND INCREASED
KNOWLEDGE IN A WILL HAS THE
BENEFITS THAT THE LOTTERY
PROVIDES AT. SCHOOL YOU REALLY
CAN AT LARGE THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE AND I THIRD GOAL IS THAT
ENSURE THAT LOTTERY IS
MAINTAINING A DISCIPLINED
OPERATING ENVIRONMENT AND IT'S
HONORABLY DURING PUBLIC FUNDS
IN A SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE
MANNER SO I'M I'M AWARE OF AND
RECOGNIZE RECENT EARNS AROUND
PERFORMANCE AND IN MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES FACING A AND- BUT
THE I. AND THE RESPONSE THE I.
T. U. S. OVERSIGHT ROLE TO
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY TO ENHANCE
FINANCIAL SIDE I TO ENSURE
PRUDENT WELL CONTROL BUSINESS
OPERATIONS. ALL TOWARDS FURTHER
MY AMAZING THE LOTTERIES
FUNDING OF PUBLIC EDUCATION SO
AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE OUR GREAT
HELLO ACT I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE CONSIDERATION AT.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
MILLS- MR STERN WELCOME. GREAT
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM PRO TEM THAT MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO
START WITH RECOGNIZING AND
THANKING MY WIFE LORI AND MY
TWO DAUGHTERS BILLION LOGIN BY
THE SIDE WAS TO A BLESSED TO
HAVE THEIR LOVE AND SUPPORT A
PROFOUNDLY APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE YOU
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
GOVERNOR DO SOME. FIRST PARTNER
JENNIFER SEAT NUMBER. STREAM
BREAK HOLD. ON THIS CALL YOU
CAN SEE. OF ME THIS ON THIS.
COMMISSION GEN CALIFORNIA AND
MY WIFE IS HUNDRED TELL MY
CHILDREN SEVEN GENERATION
CALIFORNIANS AS WELL AS MY
PARENTS HOPING RETIRED
EDUCATORS. THE LOTTERY AND
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY AND THE
LOTTERY MISSION SPECIFICALLY TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO EDUCATION IS
IT EXTREMELY NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART. AFTER A UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY IS MY
TWENTY PLUS YEAR CAREER IN
TECHNOLOGY I BRING A LOTTERY MY
DECADES OF LONG EXPERIENCE IN
INNOVATION LEADERSHIP.
ORGANIZATIONAL TRANSFORMATION
DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION. I WAS
ALSO A FORMER MEMBER OF THE U.
S. NATIONAL WATER POLO TEAM AS
WELL THE TWO TIME ALL AMERICAN
CAL BURKE. I CAN PROPERTY
LITTLE THING IN MY POWER TO
SUCCEED AND PROSPER ON BEHALF
OF THIS LOSS IN AN
ORGANIZATION. THESE ARE. THE
PLACE MY LIFE I'D WOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DEAL WITH
WASN'T OR THIS EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO. ARE YOU TODAY AND PLEASE NO
I'M DEEPLY HUMBLED VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER STERN AYE I AM GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND- I WILL START
WITH SENATOR BATES. AND WELCOME
HER BACK TO THE SCREEN. I AM
BACK THANK YOU ILL. YEAH HE'S
WITH THE- CONGRADULATIONS TO
ROB COMMISSIONER ANYTHING OR
NOT FOR YOUR REAPPOINTMENT. IF
YOU MISS MILLS AND MR STERN ON
YOUR APPOINTMENTS TO AS YOU SAY
THAT IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
COMMISSION. THE VITAL TO OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOL FUNDING- YES BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY AN HONOR AND
CERTAINLY ONE NOW THAT BASED ON
YOUR BACKGROUND. YOU ARE A VERY
VERY A COMPILATION CERTAINLY OF
THIS IS A GREAT PLACE UP FORTY
FOR YOU TO UTILIZE THOSE THOSE
SKILLS I'M GOING TO DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON QUESTIONS FOR
YOU. I WILL SAY TO YOU MISTER
STERN- MY HUSBAND WAS WATER
POLO A PLAYER WHO PLAYED ALL
COAST AT STANFORD WAITING FOR
YOUR TIME. WELL YOU ALREADY
HAVE A FEW POINTS. NUMBER TODAY
ONE WHICH YOU KNOW. SO I THANK
YOU. WE WILL I WILL DEFER TO MY
CAR SO I HAD A PRETTY ROBUST
DISCUSSION. WITH MR DIRECTOR
JOHNSON OVER THE LOTTERY IN THE
OP THE AUDITOR'S REPORT THERE
MAY BE MORE. SO THAT MY
COLLEAGUES WE SHALL NOT OF
PRETTY COUNTRY WELL ALTHOUGH I
KNOW YOU NEED TO KIND OF BE
FIVE. OF THE REVENUES SAW FOR
LOTTERY IN COLD IT HAS GOTTEN
IN THE WAY OF THAT SO YOU MIGHT
WANT TO SPEAK TO THAT OUT TO
YOU AS WE GO FORWARD. BUT LET
ME PASS OUR- MISS PROTEGER I'M
NOT CHAIRMAN HYDE TO MY
COLLEAGUE SO THAT THEY CAN ASK
A FEW OF OUR OWN THEIR- THEIR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I NGUYEN
CONGRADULATIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TAMAN I TO
WANT TO. OFFER MY
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANKS TO
EACH OF THE APPOINTEES- I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
EACH OF THEM YESTERDAY AND WE
COVER GROUND BOTH RELATED TO
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT IN
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THEY'RE RELATED TO PROCUREMENT-
WAS INTERESTED IN THEIR-
COMMITMENT TO THE- STATE
LOTTERIES. COMMITMENT TO
TROUBLED. GAMBLERS SOME PEOPLE
THAT MIGHT NEED HELP. AND THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LOTTERY WAS
RECOGNISED INTERNATIONALLY FOR
ITS EFFORTS- WITH PROBLEM
GAMBLERS SOME PROVIDING A
AVENUES FOR FAMILY MEMBERS AS
WELL AS OF THOSE THAT MAY HAVE
A PROBLEM. I ALSO NOTE THAT
FROM THE EXPERIENCE BROUGHT BY
EACH OF THESE THREE MEMBERS.
SHARE OF ANY HEARN ON THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE MISS MILLS
WITH THE CPA. IN MR STERN. AS A
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS PERSON AND
TECHNOLOGY EXPERTISE IT'S
REALLY A WONDERFUL COMPLIMENT
THAT THEY EACH BRING TO
FULFILLING THE MISSION AND- ONE
OF MY TAKEAWAYS WITH EACH OF.
THESE APPOINTEES IS COMMITTED
TO THE MISSION OF MAXIMIZING
SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION AND I THINK WE HURT
EACH ATTRIBUTE THEIR SUCCESS TO
A STRONG EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I DON'T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR FOLLOW QUESTIONS I
WOULD ONLY NOTE THAT I THINK
MISTER STEARNS. SUCCESS IN
WATER POLO WAS IT CAL BERKELEY
OM AND- I WOULD BE CURIOUS MAY
BE OFF THE RECORD TO LEARN.
WHAT THEIR RECORD WHAT THIS
AGAINST STANFORD DURING HIS
YEARS BUT I WILL WAIT FOR
ANOTHER TIME AS OUT KAY BEAR I
WANT TO THANK. FOR A- NICE
SEEING THE ROLE THAT CAL
BERKELEY PLAYED IN YOUR
EDUCATION AND SUCCESS THANK YOU
MISTER STERN THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM AND I WISH YOU ALL
THREE THE VERY BEST IN SERVING
THE PEOPLE THE STATE ACCOUNT
MORNING. WELL THANK YOU SENATOR
I COMMENTS ON CAL BERKELEY OR
STAND FOR OUR UC RIVERSIDE
WHICH IS ALREADY COME UP TODAY.
I WILL LET IT PASS I MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS
TO ALL THREE OF YOU. IT FOR
YOUR- NOMINATION I PLAN TO
SUPPORT ALL ON ALL THREE TODAY-
JUST HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THE ONE QUESTION I WANTED TO
ASK MISS MILLS MISTER TO MISS
MILLS ANSWER IN HER OPENING. SO
SHE DOESN'T THIRTY GETS A PASS
ON THIS WOULD MISTER STERN-
OBVIOUSLY YOUR NEW MEMBER OUT
WHAT ARE YOUR- GO AWAY DO YOU.
TO ACCOMPLISH. YEAH THANK YOU
SENATOR PER DAY THE QUESTION
ULTIMATELY WHEN YOU LOOK AT MY
EXPERIENCE IN TECHNOLOGY AND MY
BACKGROUND IS THE OPERATIONAL
TRANSFORMATION OPERATIONAL
EXCELLENCE- THAT THAT IT'S NEAR
TO ME AS WELL- COMMISSIONER
BUILDUP ACTUALLY RECENTLY JUST
JOINED THE AUDIT COMMITTEE AND
SO WE'RE TAKING A- LOOK ON A
CONSISTENT BASIS AROUND
OPERATION ON PREVENT. IN AREAS
THAT I THINK THAT. IT OPENS
OKAY BUT BEING THE 200-019-2000
TWENTY- CALENDAR YEAR FISCAL
YEAR THAT THE JUST ENDED WHEN
YOU YEAH I KNOW DIRECTOR
JOHNSON ALL OF YOU IN TERMS OF
CONTRIBUTION EDUCATION AND BE.
FUNDS AS IT RELATES TO THE
REVENUE AND WITH THE 13%
THRESHOLD AROUND OPERATIONS WE
ACTUALLY CAME IN THE LAST YEAR
AND IT POINT ONE PERCENT- IS A
PERCENT OF REVENUE FROM AN
OPERATIONAL PERSPECTIVE AND SO.
ALL WE WANT. WHAT'S GONNA
NATION CAN DRIVE OPERATING
ALONE YEAH I FISHING SEE AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE-
STREAMLINED PROCESS ACROSS THE
BOARD. MY UPPER BACK SOUNDS
REALLY IN THE TECHNOLOGY ON
THAT A SINGLE AND MARK MOTION
SO AS WE GO OUT. HI AND WHERE
WE CAN'T MANY THE MARK. AN OFF
LINE TO PASS TO THE THAT MUCH
IMPORTANT THAT WE AND ARE VERY
OR THAT RELATES TO MARK IT WILL
DO AN ONLINE PASSED IN THE DISH
COULD TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
RESPONSIBLE GAMING BUT- WE HAVE
THIS TERM IN MY INDUSTRY CALLED
GROW ADS WHICH IS RETURN ON ADD
SPEND OR RETURN ON MY SPENDING
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT ANY
ACTIVITY THAT WE DO AS A BALL.
ALLOCATED THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM BUT ALL LOOK AT THAT
SPECIFICALLY OURS ARE SELLING
AND MARKETING MOST MOTION AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN
MAXIMIZE ANY ACTIVITY THAT WE
PUT PORK GREAT THANK YOU THE
TO ANYBODY SO RECENTLY BEFORE
US THE DECKLID DIRECTOR IN IN
THAT PACKAGE FOR I'VE BEEN ON
THIS COMMITTEE NOW I GUESS A
COUPLE YEARS IS PRETTY WE HAD
THREE DIFFERENT LETTER.
OPPOSING IS NATION BECAUSE THEY-
LEAVE AT THE CULTURE AT THE
MISSION IS NOT. GOOD AND THEY
WERE I'M SURE THAT HE WAS THE
PERSON TO LEAD A AS A BOARD
MEMBER WHAT CAN YOU GUYS DO. TO
CHANGE SHOULD THAT MAYBE DON'T
THINK THE CULTURE NEED TO BE
CHANGED SO I WANT TO KNOW ONE
YOU DO YOU THINK THE CULTURE
NEED TO BE CHANGED IN A WHITE
AS A BOARD MEMBER CAN. YOU DO.
AB PASTORAL CARE. COMMISSIONER
STERN I'M BOB OKAY TURN AND I
HEARD BOTH THAT LOOK LIKE THEY
WERE MOVING FORWARD SO MR STERN
WHY DON'T YOU GO AHEAD AND IT
WILL TAKE SHARE A FOR HER. YEAH
I'M I'M HAPPY TO. ANSWER FIRST
AND FOREMOST SO. ANY ANY
ORGANIZATION THAT. ESPECIALLY
THE LOTTERY BEING ESTABLISHED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR- WE
REALLY WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK
AT THE OPERATION AND
CONSTANTLY- DRIVER OPERATIONAL
EXCELLENCE BUT ALSO MAKE. MAKE
SURE THE CULTURE THE FALLING.
OTHER DAY AND SO WE ALREADY
HAVE PROGRAM WE'RE REVIEWING AT
THE COMMISSION LEVEL TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE HAVE. PERSON AT
THAT ARE COMING ON BOARD LOOK
THE SPECIFIC. WHICH ARE BURKE
THAT WE'VE ALREADY STARTED OUT
TO IMPLEMENT IN THE WE ALSO
JUST ROLLED OUT EMPLOYEE
SURVEY. ACTUALLY GET BOTTOM UP
FEEDBACK- FROM THE
ORGANIZATION- ORGANIZATIONAL
WIDE SO- IT'S NOT JUST THAT IT
THE COMMISSION AND THE SENIOR
STAFF- FOLLOWING A PARTICULAR-
PROGRAM IT'S WE'RE ALSO GETTING
REAL TIME FEEDBACK FROM- THE
EMPLOYEES SPECIFIC. WHICH I
THINK GETTING BACK WILL HELP US
DRIVE TRAIN ON THE WAY GREAT
THANK YOU. MISSION OR A HUNDRED
YOU WANT TO COMMENT. YEAH I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO. HAVE MY
FULL SUPPORT FOR- DIRECTOR
JOHNSON HE HAS BEEN VERY. VOCAL
WITH US HE'S BEEN VERY
TRANSPARENT INVOLVES NOT ONLY
THE COMMISSIONERS BUT- IS STAFF
IN ALL OF OUR MEETINGS. I'M NOT
SURE NAY AND ALL OF THEM ARE
VERY DEDICATED TO MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE THE FINEST STANDARDS
AND- FOLLOW THEIR STRATEGIC
PLAN. TO MAXIMIZE PROFITS FOR
CATION HI I THINK HIS MOTIVES
ARE OF. WHAT WE WANT TO SEE OUR
DIRECTOR AND I THINK HE IS UP
IN ON PEOPLE THAT ALL OF THE
SOUL. BUT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PUBLIC IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE
AND- HE'S DONE A WONDERFUL JOB
AND SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED FOR
THAT AND HE'S ALSO DONE
SOMETHING MANAGEMENT. OUR
VISION THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BECAUSE OF THE NEED FOR A
BETTER OVERSIGHT NINE I CALLED
HIM ON HIS WORK. BY THE TIME
FIVE. YOUR BILL SO I DON'T WANT
TO OVERLOOK YOU IF YOU WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING TO THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BUT- THEY GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY. OUR SENATOR ROTH A
BROAD TERM MERGING
COMMISSIONERS CONGRATULATIONS
ACTUALLY HAVE NO QUESTIONS OF
YOU- I LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
YOUR CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I DO HAVE A
QUESTION PENDING WITH YOUR
DIRECTOR. AND I WILL AWAITING A
RESPONSE I WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
HIM NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SENATOR AND I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR- FOR YOUR COMMENTS
YOUR QUESTIONS AND- BETWEEN.
THE HEARING WHERE WE WERE ABLE
TO HEAR FROM THE DIRECTOR AND
NOW WITH THIS COMMISSIONERS. I
CERTAIN THAT THE ALTAR AND THE
CHANGED PROBLEM NEEDS TO HAPPEN
IS HAPPENING AND ARE.
APPRECIATE YOUR FORTHRIGHT
CONVERSATION WITH US TODAY. I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO OUR
MEMBERS. I AS I DO I'M GOOD TO
KEEP THAT PHONE ONE MORE TIME
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S POSTED
ON THE SCREEN FOR THOSE WHO
WANT TO CALL IN AND THAT PHONE
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN FIVE
ZERO TWO ZERO ONE HE. IT IS ON
THE SCREEN AND THE WEBSITE. AND
THEN I'M GOING TO BUSINESSES
AND SCORED RICK THIRTY NINETY.
AND SEE NO ONE I STEP FOR LET
ME GO AHEAD AND GO ROOM TWO
FORTY. AND SEEING NO ONE THERE
LET ME WELCOME BACK OUR
MODERATOR. MATTER MODERATOR ARE
YOU THERE. MA'AM I'M HERE
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN AS
REMINDERS ELECT A SOCIAL
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AND I SHOW NO ONE'S SO
WITH REPORT AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF MATTER MODERATOR
OKAY WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL COME BACK
INTO ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
AND SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY JUST TO
DOUBLE CHECK THAT THERE'S NO
ONE WAITING IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MADAME MODERATOR I'M
GONNA COME BACK TO YOU NOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I SHOW NO ONE
SHOWING OPPOSITION AT THIS
MOMENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH MADE
A MODERATOR MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR ROTH MADAM SECRETARY
WILL YOU PLEASE- AND WE'RE GOOD
ALL THREE AT THE SAME TIME
GREAT JUST DOUBLE CHECKING
BOTTOM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
LINING I MEAN I ROTH ROTH AYE
WILK HI LOOK I ATKINS AYE
INSIDE FOUR ZERO COMMISSIONERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THANK YOU. AND YOUR
PATIENCE FOR THE FOR THE
HEARING TODAY WE ARE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO ITEM ONE
G. THAT IS THE APPOINTMENT OF
MARION SPEARMAN SENIOR
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
MR SPEARMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND WHAT BETTER THANK
YOU AND WELCOME WANNA LET YOU
GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE ANYONE-
THANK ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
THE PARTICULAR MAKE YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS. AND THEN
WE'LL COME RIGHT BACK TO THE
SPIDERS TO GET STARTED WELCOME
GO HEY. GOOD AFTERNOON MAYOR
PRO TEM AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE. I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR IT AND
INVITING ME AND HEAR MY
APPOINTMENT TODAY. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOUR STAFFERS
AND THE STAFFERS IN THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE WILL KIND OF
HELP ME UNDERSTAND AND GET
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. ALSO ONE
THING- GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
FOR THE APPOINTMENT I
APPRECIATE HIS CONFIDENCE. IN
ME TO SERVE IN THIS CAPACITY AS
AN ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR. DUE TO
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SAYING OUT MY
DEAR FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
WATCHING WHAT FAR. YOU ALL KNOW
I LOVE ALL OF YOU. AND NOT I
ALSO PRE SHALL ALL THE SUPPORT
ALL OF YOU'VE GIVEN ME AND MY
FAMILY- THROUGHOUT MY CAREER IS
SERVICING DEPARTMENT.
FURTHERMORE ONE THINK MY CDC
OUR FAMILIES A LOT OF PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE OF REACHED OUT
TO ME THIS MORNING AND SAID.
HOLES IN. CALLED ME THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR BEING ONLINE A
WATCHING THIS AND FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO MY CAREER. IT IS TWO
PRIMARY THINGS THAT HAVE A-
HELP ME WITH MY LONGEVITY IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
I'VE BEEN A DEPARTMENT FOR
QUITE A WHILE A STANDARD
APARTMENT MOVES IN THAT
DIRECTION THAT'S VERY VERY
POSITIVE ARE WE REALLY TRULY
ARE DOING ARE CDC ARE AND
EXPOSING OUR OFFENDERS TO SELL
REHABILITATIVE. PROGRAMS AND
MANY OF THEM ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THAT AND DOING
WELL AS THEY ARE RELEASED IN
THE COMMUNITY AND THOSE WHO
STAY WITH US AND HAVE A LONG
TERM. CITIZENS ANTI. SO WITH
THAT SAID THERE'S TWO THINGS
ACT AGAINST ARMY AND ONE IS
COACHING AND MENTORING STAFF.
HELPING PEOPLE TO GET WHERE
THEY WANT TO BE WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT THERE'S MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS OF OUR
DEPARTMENT THAT A PERSON TO
WORK IN. THE SIDES OF GRAYSON.
GOALS BORDER BRO HEARINGS THEY
CAN WORK AND THE APARTMENT THE
REAL BILL TAPE PROGRAMS- THEY
CAN WORK AND EDUCATION MEDICAL
ON MANY DIFFERENT AREAS SO THAT
INSPIRES ME TO CONTINUE DOING.
ITS CULTURE MENTORING HELP
PEOPLE IN THE SECOND INNING
HE'S ME COMING BACK IS SEE IF
THAT SELL REAL OKAY CHANGE
REALIZE AND BE CONFERRED SAID.
INSIDE REYES. IN A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE VERY UP
AMERICAN FIRST PART OF THEIR
TERMS AND AS A KIND OF MATURED
IN AGE DOUBT A IN NOW ARE
PRODUCTIVE PEOPLE TAKE THE SO
WE'LL TAKE A LOT OF POSITIVE
THINGS THAT TAKE PLACE. WITHIN
OUR SINS. AND ALL I SEE SOME
PEOPLE CON EVERY NOW IS AN E. I.
THERE WERE AS THANKS. BUT IN
CLOSING THEIR TO GROW OF PEOPLE
BABEL APPARATE FOR WRIST. THAT
I HAVE TO RECOGNIZE BECAUSE
WITHOUT THESE TWO GROUPS OF
PEOPLE I WOULDN'T BE HERE
SITTING YOUR FRONT YOU TODAY.
AND THEY ARE THE EXTRAORDINARY
HEART WORKING EMPLOYEES AT HIGH
DESERT STATE PRISON IN
SUSANVILLE. AND AT THE CRESSMAN
TRAINING THE SOLELY AND SOLD
AT. I LEARNED A LOT FROM MANY
OF YOU. YOU PUSH ME TO BE THE
BEST WARDEN I COULD BE TRUE YOU.
ALWAYS BE DATED TO YOU FOR
MAKING MY TENURE WITH YOU
SUCCESSFUL. AND SO WITH THAT.
MADAM PRO JAM I'LL TURN IT BACK
OVER TO YOU FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU SO MUCH LET ME GO AHEAD AND
GO TO SENATOR BATES WHO IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND
START WITH YOU SENATOR BATES.
THERE WE GO I THINK YOU ARE A
MEMBER. YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR OB I THINK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THIRTY THREE YEARS
OF FASHION IN. STUFF IN THIS
DAY ON BOB CORRECTIONS SANDRA
ARE YOU ARE KNOWN FOR BEING A
OUR CULTURE CHANGER AND GETTING
IN THERE AND I'LL GIVE YOU
CHARTER- ON SENTIMENT EXISTED
IN AN ARSON TERMS. I JUST. AND
RIGHT THANK YOU. KNOWLEDGE HERE
ARE H. IN ON THIS PARTICULAR
GROUP. OUT SPEAKS SOME I THINK
OF THE HOUSE WORDS HI IN TERMS
OF WITH YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE IS
YOUR- AND CERTAINLY ON THE AIR
BY WHICH YOU IN YOUR- I JUST
WANT AND JOB IN A WILL BE SOME
OF THE OTHER TWO EXPAND IT TO
DO CONTRABAND. I'VE BEEN VERY.
JOHN THE DRUG ISSUES THE DRUG.
AND DOG AXE TO DRUGS AND JOHN
THE CONTRABAND. OKAY AND I KNOW
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING. WITH BUT
WE HAD A LOT DISCUSSION IAN-
ARE SENATE TIME HE GOES IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN ABOUT THE
DRAWING THE- YET TO BEING
SOMETHING OUT. OPERA AT SOME
OUTSIDE OF OUR CREW FACILITIES
TO BE ABLE TO IMPORT INTO THOSE
FACILITIES SOME OF THESE VERY
VERY ODD DANGEROUS AND I THINK
YOU HAVE TO. DO WE HAVE ANY
PROGRESS ON THAT FRONT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT. YOU YOU CAN
SHARE WITH LOS WE'RE ACTUALLY
TO THE CORNER IS THE TOP. ONE
THING THAT WE DID WHEN I FIRST
STONE THIS ROLE HERE WAS WE
WERE ABLE THAT WE DID A- THREE
MONTH DRONE DETECTION TRIAL WE
HAD DIFFERENT VENDORS. IT
DIDN'T PROVE REAL SUCCESSFUL.
HOWEVER SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE DO HAVE IN PLACE IS. BEFORE
WE- OUR RECREATION YARDS FOR A-
ACTIVITY DAY WE HAVE WHAT'S
CALLED OF SINCE THIS CALL SIX
THREE BRIDGE OFFICER THEY WILL
WHAT DO A THREE VERY STERILE TO
THE AIR LOOK TO SEE IF THERE
WERE ANY OWN DROPS BECAUSE MOST
OF THE ONE THAT. WAY ONLY AT
NIGHT OUR HOURS OF TENNIS THIS
WAS A SLAP IN THE- WE ALSO HAVE
THE SAME OFF THAT WERE. OUR OF
OUR WHILE OFFICE THAT WILL LOOK
AT OUR OUTER PERIMETER AND ARE
NO. LAND AREA. LOOKING FOR DROP
AND- HI YOUR MAN AND WE HAVE
SOME. AND THEN EACH GRAYSON HAS
AN AND- SERVICES UNIT THAT ALSO
YOU KNOW THEY WATCH SOCIAL
MEDIA AND THEY THE AND THEY
HAVE. SOME CONFIDENCE FORMA SO
WE'LL TALK WITH THEM AND JUST
SAY HEY YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS
TAKING PLACE. MY BASS KIND OF
HARPER COMBAT AND EVERY NOW-
WHEN I CLOSED OFF TO IT BUT-
ANY DAY TRIAL IT WASN'T VERY
VERY SUCCESSFUL. THIS. GO AHEAD
I'M GONNA SAY VERY DIFFICULT
ARE YOU I WOULD ASSUME ON ON ON
THAT PARTICULAR THING WITH THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED IF IT'S
GOING ON NIGHT TIME AND ALL OF
THAT AND THE ABILITY FOR THE
BRONZE YOU DO OUR OUR CAR EVERY
WE SAY. WERE YOU LOOKING TO.
ARE YOU. I SOMETHING. THANK YOU
WE CAN HELP OUR CERTAINLY
LEGISLATIVE OR OTHERWISE OUT
SOMETHING I THINK WE'RE ALL
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT. THANK YOU
AND ONE OTHER THING I WAS A
MENTION IF A DRONE IS
ATTEMPTING TO DROP SOMETHING
OFF. IN THE HOURS OF DAYLIGHT
WE HAVE STAFF LIKE AN ELEVATED
POSE AN OBSERVATION COMPOSED
AROUND OUR PERIMETERS AND OUR
RECREATION YARDS AND SOULS
PEOPLE'S JOBS UP TO SCAN WAS
TAKING PLACE. OUR THE SEASON I
WILL WORK FOR. WITH A STAFF
BROWN AND WE GO AHEAD MAKE A
RECORD. YEAH I THINK ANOTHER OF
YOUR CONCERN ARE THE RE. THAT
VENDOR. YEAH A QUICK. I WHAT
YOU'RE- PERHAPS THE- YOU KNOW
PREPARE OFF FOR THE STAFF EVERY
SO YOU'RE GOING TO NEED YOU
KNOW IN THE EVENTUALLY THERE IS
ANY NOW ALSO ACCESS. WHENEVER
YOU WANT YOUR OUT MAGICGATE.
WELL ONE THING THAT I HAVE DONE
IS I TRY TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
YOU KNOW BECAUSE THEY TURN
FIFTY I WAS ASK A PERSON IN
I'LL LET ME ASK DIRE SOME
PEOPLE CANNOT WHEN I PUT IT
THAT WAY TO THEY SAID NOT
REALLY AT ALL. AND SO I. IF
THEY SHORT THEY'RE DOING AND
ARE HAPPY WITH THEIR DON'T. TO
CONTINUE TO WORK I ALSO DO IS.
THE EYES AND EARS FOR A
DIRECTOR ALL OF US THE SOCIAL
DIRECTORS SO WE'RE ALWAYS OUT
THERE COACHING AND MENTORING
YOUNGER MANAGERS PEOPLE AT THAT
LEVEL OF AYE CAPTAIN ARE SO
SURE WHARTON AND- HELP PEOPLE
TO THEIR CAREERS BUT WHEN I
ACTUALLY TO. LAST THING I WAS A
CHILD WITH PEOPLE OF AGE THERE
OFFICES AT THAT LEVEL AND JUST
KIND OF IN A ENCOURAGED AND
THAT- THAT THEY'RE FUTURE
LEADERS OF THE. AND QUESTION
MIGHT ALWAYS CHEN AT PEOPLE
WHERE THEY SEE THEMSELVES IN
FIVE YEARS HELLO OF PEOPLE TELL
ME WANT TO BE. MY YOU WERE IN
SO THEN WE HAVE DEEP
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE- AND I
GIVE THEM BACK ON HOW THEY IT
HOW THEY COULD ACTUALLY
ATTAINMENT GOAL. GREAT WHAT.
HOUSE THANK YOU CAN BE PRETTY
GOOD MISSING AND SOME OF THOSE
SURROUNDING OR SO AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CALL SHOT OF TWO
SOB SHE GREW PROFESSIONS. THANK
YOU JOHN. ARE HAVE A VERY
STELLAR CAREER I IN YOUR
RESUME- WE SHOULD THE VERY BEST
YOU GO FORWARD IN THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS AND WHEN I
BACK NOT REMOTE THE FLORIDA.
YOUR CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU
YEAH SENATE RACE THANK YOU ARE
SENATOR ROTH. THE MAYOR PRO TEM
US SIR NO QUESTIONS
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU DO FOR. SENATE ROTH
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS ON THIS
APPOINTMENT AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU AS WELL FOR YOUR SERVICE
ALSO THE GOVERNOR'S TALKED
ABOUT AT TURNER POSSIBLY TO
PRISONS NOW JUST CURIOUS IF WE
WERE TO DO THAT WHAT WOULD BE
TO. TERRY AND MAKE SELECTIONS.
WHEN IT COMES IT ADDS UNDER
WILL SIGN DON'T HAVE THE
PERFUME SO THAT THAT DECISION
WILL BE MADE BETWEEN. IS AND
THE GOV. WE GOT A PART TAMI. I
AM NOT PART OF THAT AT ALL CAN
KIND OF AGAIN ONE OF MY MAIN
GOALS FOR ME. MANAGER CALLED IT
NINETEEN RIGHT NOW IN OUR
PRISONS OKAY I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT. IF THAT'S YOUR GOAL
THIS HERE ABOUT THAT. WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN MY PRISON TIME
AND I WAS TALKING ABOUT EARLIER
IN THE HEARING WELL WE HAD
ALLEN ALL STATE PRISON THAT HAD
QUITE A FEW UP. ALMOST ALMOST A
THOUSAND. AS IF CASES AS OF
TODAY THERE'S FORTY CASES.
TROUBLE WHILE I VALLEY PRESENT
ON IN LIFE. AT BIRTH THAT BASE
AND THEY'RE DOWN ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED NINETY ONE CASES TODAY.
SO I KNOW WORKING WITH. I WORE.
SURE IT BUYS ONE ASK THAT WE
ARE. SOCIAL DOES WHAT
DISTANCING. AT WAR. MY PARTNER
OUR HELP. THE CALIFORNIA PRESS
ONE HEALTH KERR. BUT. OR YARDS
AT AT TIME. WE HAVE HAND
SANITIZER WE WHEN I THINK CAL
P. I. A FOR PROVIDING BILLS A
MASK FOR US AND OURS ARE THE
INMATE POPULATION SO. THAT'S
HOW WE'RE DOING IT AGAIN IT'S
BEEN VERY POSITIVE THE WORD WE
HAD COAL BUT IT DOES TO PRISONS
AND S. ON DOWN STICKLEY. WHAT'S
THE PROCESS SEES CHANGED LOT
I'VE GOT LANCASTER STATE PRISON
IN MY DISTRICT. AND I HAD THE
OFFICERS REACH OUT TO ME
BECAUSE THEY WERE CONCERNED
THAT THEY DIDN'T FEEL LIKE
THERE IS ADEQUATE POTA. PLACE
IN. THE TO THE BURDEN NOTIONS
KINDA RE BY OFTEN I'M NOT SURE
WHAT THE CURRENT STATUS IS
THERE BUT THEY DID LIKE A LOT
OF PLACES THEY THEY DID EXPLODE
SO. HAS BEEN CHANGE IS. AT THE
DEPARTMENT ON ON A DRESS CODE
IN SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE-
THINGS THAT THEY WERE BEING
DONE TO PROTECT A- THE OFFICERS
AS WELL AS THE INMATES. YEAH
IT'S KIND OF LIKE I TELL
EVERYBODY GIVES NEW. IT IS
CROSSED ACROSS THE WORLD WAS
NEW TO ALL OF US SO
EVERYTHING'S VERY VERY FLUENT
BUT ONE BACK I CAN SAY THAT YOU
HAVE A VERY GOOD WHARTON
WORKING JOHNSON DOWN HIGHER AND
THAT HE HAD A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT CASES. AND AS A I
THINK. WE SET HE HAS. A CASE OF
HOW GRAY HERE. HIM AND HIS SEE
DOWN IT EXCELLENT JOB IN HOW
THEY MANAGE THAT ENDEMIC ON
THERE. OKAY GREAT AGAIN THANKS
FOR ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT I GET
A LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
YOUR CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR WELLS THANK YOU SENATE
ON AND- THANK YOU A- MAN PRO
TEM IN- I JUST WANT ALSO OFFER
MY- GRADUATIONS TO YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN IN AND THANKS FOR A
DEDICATED CAREER OF SERVICE- WE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET AT
THE CALIFORNIA TRAINING
FACILITY IN SOLID AT A FEW
YEARS AGO AND I. HE IS TO
REMEMBERING THAT IN. IN THE
TOUR THAT I WAS PROVIDED WHEN I
VISITED THERE. I ALSO WANT TO
FOLLOW UP WE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY AND SOME
OF THE CONTRABAND ISSUES RAISED
BY SENATOR BATES COVERT
NINETEEN. YOU DID GO THROUGH A
VERY SPECIFIC AND DETAILED
REPORTING BY INSTITUTION DURING
OUR CONVERSATION. I DIDN'T HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING THIS MORNING OF
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
BUT I HAVE READ SOME REPORTS OF
SOME IN MANY COMPLAINTS ABOUT
GUARDS NOT WEARING MASKS EVEN
THOUGH THAT IS THE PROTOCOL IN
THE MORNING IF YOU COULD MAYBE
JUST COMMENT ON. IS THERE ANY
CONSEQUENCE OF GUARDS WERE
STAFF DON'T WEAR MASKS WHAT
WHAT ARE THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS AND HOW IS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BROUGHT TO
YOUR ATTENTION THIS IN IN. HAVE
A WAY TO BRING THAT TO THE
ATTENTION OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
DOUBLE L. INCIDENT AS- WE HAVE
WE HAVE TODAY THIS MORNING I
THINK THAT WAS A FOURTH MEMO
THAT WAS ISSUED RELATIVE TO THE
MANDATORY WEARING OF MASS. WE
HAVE OUR CAPTAINS OUT DOING A
WEEKLY TOUR- UNDER OUR
DIRECTORS LEADER IF WE PUT
TOGETHER CAPTAIN'S CHECK LISTEN
TO OUR- AND THEY GO. AND THE
WARDENS ARE OUT WEEKLY WALK
AROUND IT'S FACT ENTIRE
MANAGING TEAMS OUT AND PACIFIC
WE WILL LOOK AT IT MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE FOLLOWING.
THOSE COLD AT NINETEEN
PROTECTIONS AND THE MAIN THING
IS ASS IF SOMEONE IS NOT
WEARING A MASK AND IS JUST A
SLIP OF SOMETHING THAT'S ONE
THING BUT IF SOMEONE IS
RECALCITRANT AND SAYS THAT
THERE ARE OR WHERE MASTER. IT'S
JUST TOO HOT. PERSON WILL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY YOU KNOW
THE HIRING PARTY WHICH IS A
WOOD WORKING AT YOUR PRESENT.
AND IF SOMEONE WAS IS IF AN
INMATE OR A FAMILY MEMBER WAS A
SENSE SOMETHING OR ANY BY WAS
AND THAT TO ME. EMAIL WHICH I
GET A LOT OF EMAILS FROM FAMILY
MEMBERS DIFFERENT THINGS AND OF
COURSE I WOULD REFER THAT BACK
TO THE ARE WITH THE REWARDS.
AND HAVE THAT PERSON LOOK INTO
THAT TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
LEGITIMACY. LEGITIMACY TO
WHAT'S BEING SAID. WE
APPRECIATE THAT WE DID TALK
SOME ABOUT WITH THE SUSPENSION.
OF FAMILY VISIT SIR GUEST
VISITS TO INMATES AS PART OF
THE CODE. NINETEEN PROTOCOL YOU
SHARED SOME OF THE EXPANDED.
TELEPHONIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INMATES TO CONNECT WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS- SO THE BIGGEST.%
SUSCEPTIBILITY I WOULD GUESS IS
STAFF COMING IN AND OUT WHO
WERE. NOT CONTAINED IN THAT
INSTITUTION THEY'RE GOING HOME
TO FAMILIES AND- OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY SO. APPS THE GREATEST
RISK IN THESE INSTITUTIONS FOR.
VIRUS BEING BROUGHT IN IS
EITHER IN MAKE TRANSFER OR
STAFF IN GUARD SO JUST A LITTLE
BIT MORE ON THE- CONSEQUENCE
SINCE IT IS REQUIRED FOR GUARDS
AND STAFF TO WEAR MASKS. IN A
FULL WAS BROUGHT HERE
ATTENTION- WARDEN'S ATTENTION
FORGET FOR A BUT MORE ACTIVE
FINANCE. WOULD THERE BE A
DISCIPLINARY ACTION ASSOCIATED
WITH WITH PERSISTENT
RECALCITRANCE ON THE MASK
REQUIREMENTS. YES THERE WOULD
BE WITHIN OUR EMPLOYED THIS
PRINTER PROCESS A PERSONAL THE
FIRST OFFENSE TO BE WRITTEN ON
A EMPLOYEE COUNTING BROWN ALL
PERSON DID IT AGAIN WE WRITE
THEM A LETTER OF INSTRUCTION
AND A SOMEBODY WAS REALLY JUST
OBSTINATE RECALCITRANT AND THAT
WILL BE REFERRED FOR ADVERSE
ACTION. AN OLD WHERE SOMEONE
COULD. CERTAIN CHANNELS HE'S
PUT UPON THEM MONETARILY THAT.
WOULD AFFECT THEM. ONE THING
THAT WE DO WITH OUR STAFF IS WE
DOA LOT OF EDUCATION WAS STAFF
AND THE OFFENDER POPULATION. ON
THE SERIOUSNESS OF WHY THE NEED
TO WEAR THE MASK. WE PROVIDE
PEOPLE MASS WE ALLOW STAFF TO
WEAR MASKS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
APPROPRIATE FOR THE WORKPLACE
THAT THEY'RE COMFORTABLE WITH.
AND SO I LEAST I'M NOT AND MY
TO PRESERVE MY MISSION- THE
WARDENS AND IMAGINE TEAMS ABOUT
OUT I'VE TOURED THE PRISONERS
I'VE SEEN PEOPLE IN MASS.
AVENUE COMPLAINTS IS FROM MY
NEW PRISONS OF THAT BUT YES
THERE WILL PEOPLE WILL BE.
IMAGINE IF IN A IT'S BEEN FOR
MEMEL BUT OUT ON THE
SERIOUSNESS. AND THE MANDATE
THAT STAFF AND THAT- YA
EXTENDERS WERE MASS TO. HELP
PREVENT IT PANDEMIC ONE THING I
DID MENTION I AM NOT SURE WE
TALK ABOUT A COUPLE DAYS AGO IS
THAT WE CHECK EVERY PERSON THAT
COMES ON GROUNDS EVERY DAY NO
MATTER CONTRACTOR DELIVERING
FOOD WHATEVER IT IS WE ASK THEM
THE QUESTIONS FOR STREET. AND
WE ALSO CHECK THAT PERSON'S
TEMPERATURE IF SOMEONE SAYS YES
TO ONE OF THE SCREENING RIGHT
REPORTER TEMPERATURES ABOVE A
HUNDRED POINTS FOR. AN EFFORT
TO TURN AROUND AND THEY'RE NOT
ABOUT THE INSTITUTION. THANK
YOU AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF NATURE OF HOUSE DO
YOU NOT OR HAVE ANY. THIS ORDER.
GEN FOR STAFF OT A MASS I
BELIEVE ONE OF OUR MISSIONS
I'VE WHEN I FEAR IS OTHERS I
THINK BEEN A LETTER OF
INSTRUCTION ISSUED AND I THINK
I'M PRESENT THERE MAY BE-
SOMEONE PENDING ADVERSE ACTION
AND I APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE I
THINK WE FACE THE PROBLEM.
GENERAL PUBLIC OF COURSE BUT IN
WORK PLACES I AM PARTICULARLY
IN AN INSTITUTION HOLDING. THE
PEOPLE CAPTIVE TO PAY FOR THEIR
CRIMES- THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
WIGGLE ROOM IN IN SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING I THINK IF WORD IS
OUT THAT THERE IS A CONSEQUENCE
FOR NOT WEARING A MASK- THAT'S
PROBABLY GOING TO BE THE BEST
MECHANISM TO ENFORCE. SOME IT'S
CLOSE 2100% COMPLIANCE AS WE
CAN GET BUT AGAIN I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CANDOR IN YOUR ANSWERS
AND AGAIN APPRECIATE YOUR-
YEARS OF SERVICE AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU AGAIN
SOME DAY SOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'LL BE BACK RUNNING
HERE MISSION TO THANK YOU.
SEVEN LET ME JUST SAY I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN PARTICULAR- ONE A
GO BACK TO A COMMENT- FROM
SENATOR BATES WHO TALKED ABOUT
YOUR HISTORY AND ROLL AT SEA R.
I. EGGS. OF OBVIOUSLY IT'S WHY
YOU'RE FOR US TODAY- YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR BILLS
EXPERIENCE SOMEONE AG COMMEND
YOU FOR THAT- AT THAT I CUT AND
AB SUPPORTING HER CAR. TO THIS
IS MORE OF A GENERAL COMMENT
BECAUSE IT HAVE A HEARING
EARLIER TODAY THE PUBLIC AFETY
COMMITTEE AND IT WAS AN
EXTENSIVE HEARING WITH
HAVE TO SAY FOR THE RECORD
BECAUSE I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THERE ARE SENATORS THAT ARE
INCREDIBLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC. YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
WERE DEALING WITH BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC OCCURRED IN TERMS OF
ALL OF THE QUESTIONS WE WOULD
TYPICALLY BE TALKING ABOUT. YOU
KNOW THE GROUND THE HAITIAN AND
AN AYE CONTRABAND AND ALL THOSE
THINGS WHICH ARE CRITICAL. AND
YOU HAVE. ANY OF US EVER MANAGE
ON I WOULD CLOSE SO- THIS IS
NOT IN PARTICULAR TO YOU BUT IN
TERMS OF THE CASES- OF IT IS
YOU KNOW I'D SAY OF THE
SECRETARY OF OUR SENATE HAS A
HARD TIME. GETTING PEOPLE IN
THE BUILDING WHERE MASS. LE AND
SO I UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGE
IN THE DILEMMA THAT YOU FACE AS
SOMEONE IN IN CHARGE AND
RESPONSIBILITY. BUT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO THE DIRECTOR
TO US WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
HERE- TO THE STAFF INTO THE
MADE A WE OF WORK. BECAUSE I
SITUATE. GOOD TERMS WHAT IS
HAPPENED AT NIGHT AT A FACILITY
THAT- DIRECTORS BERMAN OVERSEAS
BUT WHAT HAS HAPPENED AT SAN
QUENTIN IS OKAY AND THOSE
TRANSFERS AND WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT AND WE HAVE WORK TO
DO THE VAPOR ON THIS PARTICULAR
APPOINTMENT. ALL I AND NOT TO
TAKE. FROM FIVE YOUR IT. CAREER
WE ARE IN A PANDEMIC AND WE ALL
HAVE WORK TO DO AND I JUST
CAN'T LET THIS HEARING GO
FORWARD WITHOUT KIND OF
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL. AND WITH THAT IN
MIND WE NEED TO GIVE YOU THE
SUPPORT. WE NEED TO GIVE YOU
THE SUPPORT THE ABLE TO YOUR
JOB WITH FACILITIES THAT YOU
OVERSEE AND SO WE HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE OUR POLAND AND YET AT
THE SAME TIME SAM PROUD TO
SUPPORT YOUR- OUR CONFIRMATION
TODAY. AND THEN WE CONTINUE
WHAT WE NEED. IN OUR ROLES AND
HOPEFULLY THAT MEANS WE WILL
FOLLOW THE RULES AS WELL. I'M
GRADUATION GOING TO GO TO THE
PUBLIC BUT LET ME ARE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY AND AS IT
MOVES FORWARD AND I WISH YOU
THE BEST BECAUSE YOU HAVE A BIG
JOB I THOUGHT YOU ALREADY HAD A
BIG JOB IT IS BEEN MADE MORE BY
THE PRESIDENT AT. SO YOU HAVE
MY THANK YOU MADAM. THANK YOU
CAN I APPRECIATE THAT. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN PORT AND RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
SEEING NO ONE STEPPING FORWARD
TO THE MIKE LET ME ADD TURN TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY JUST TO MAKE
SURE. WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE
STEPPING FORWARD OKAY- MANTA
MODERATOR I AM COMING BACK TO
YOU ON THE TELECONFERENCE TO
SEE IF THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF DIRECTORS BERMAN. YES LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I DO
HAVE ONE PERSON TO BE JUST ONE
MOMENT ARE CURRENTLY WITHIN
OPERATOR WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE TO OPEN A
LINE OF MY NUMBER CAN LINE
TENURE LINE IS NOW OPEN.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME.
MY NAME'S MATT DILLON BOEHME
BACK CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION. ON
BEHALF OF OUR- STATE BOARD AND
ARE NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS. LIKE YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THIRTY PLUS
YEARS OF SERVICE. AND. BUT YOU
GUYS KNOW THE WE HAVE- RESEARCH
FIRM HAS THE FULL SUPPORT OF
CCS SO STATE BOARD DIRECTORS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- MADAME
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
ON THE LAWN. I HAVE NO THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY COLLEAGUES SO WE WILL COME
BACK INTO ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION. AND
I SEE NO ONE STEPPING FORWARD
IN OPPOSITION WE WILL CHECK OUT
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S NO WAITING THERE THERE
IS NOT. MADAME MODERATOR WE'RE
COMING RIGHT BACK TO YOU TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ON THE LINE I
IN OPPOSITION. CERTAINLY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE. MADAME
MODERATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR HELP AND SUPPORT TODAY WE
APPRECIATE IT. OUR COLLEAGUES I
WILL COME BACK INTO THE ROOM.
THAT IS. ROBB HAS MADE THE
MOTION. I TO SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION MADAM SECRETARY
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ONLINE I AM WANTING AYE ROTH
ARE ROTH AYE WILK ALL RIGHT
WILK AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS I
GRADUALLY DIRECTOR SPEARMAN.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
SUPPORT NOT GIVE YOU THE BEST
THAT I CAN. I KNOW THAT YOU
WILL THANK YOU AND GOOD LUCK. A
LET'S SEE SO NOW WE WILL TAKE
UP I THINK WE HAVE A FUN MY
AGENDA THE FINAL ITEM AND THAT
WOULD BE OUR GOVERNOR'S ITEMS
ARE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR THAT'S ALL
RIGHT TO H. THROUGH AGAIN I
WANT TO OUR CHECK AND SEE IF WE
NEED TO. VOTE FROM ANY MEMBERS
OKAY. OKAY SO THEM I REMOVED IT
SENATOR RALPH MOVED- ITEM TWO
ITEMS H. THROUGH IN. OUR MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. MY I
AYE ROTH ARE ROTH AYE WILK AYE
WILK AYE ATKINS HI I CAN SORRY.
THAT IS CONFIRMED FOR TWO ZERO
LET ME SAY THANK YOU I. THAT IS
THE END OF THE AGENDA AND SO
LET ME JUST SAY THE FOLLOWING I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. I
IF YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO TESTIFY
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES ATTY ARE VISIT OUR
WEBSITE EIGHT FOR INSTRUCTION.
YOUR COMMENT IN SUGGEST ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. SO
THANK YOU AND AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
I TO MY COLLEAGUES LET ME SAY
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE EXECUTIVE
SESSION- BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ON. FOR THE WORK WE ARE
DOING WE ARE TRYING.
MAINTENANCE AND IN THE MIDST OF
THIS AND MY OLLEAGUES IN MY
VICE CHAIRMAN HAVE WORKED VERY
HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
GETTING THESE APPOINTMENTS DONE
BECAUSE THEY ARE IMPORTANT. TO
THE PEOPLE- THAT IT IS.
RELEVANT TO AND CERTAINLY TO
THE ADMINISTRATION TO OUR STATE
SONG I THANK. THAT SO WE WILL.
INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION.